what's up guys and welcome to the gray
area this is a little segment by myself
and pearl we will be going into
different subjects i don't know why
we've called it the great area pearl why
we call it a great area i can't think of
a single reason no black and white don't
make gray did it
nah nah i've never had never heard of
that um but yeah this is the gray area
and um i hope you guys you know enjoy
okay guys um by the way do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it sign up for our memberships
um jess is actually going to be doing
some behind the behind the scenes
content
and um don't forget to turn on your
notifications so you're notified when we
are live
so sorry no go ahead go ahead not go
impaling i was just going to say so um
sarah tell us about today's topic yeah
so today's topic we're going to be going
into
should men
record themselves
in the presence of women
for their own
protection so that is we've said it or
i'm saying it or i'm asking the question
because of the whole johnny depp and
amber her thing right so
had we not heard the recordings of
johnny depp
and uh amber then people would have
thought based on what amber said that
she was you know the victim and he was
the perpetrator comes to find out that
it wasn't generally that way
um
so that's why i'm asking the question
but i guess before we get started we
need to go and meet our audience and
whoever whoever is like speaking on this
so if you all go around one by one and
then just say your name
your relationship status
and where people can find you
you go first
okay um so my name is karita
um my relation status i'm really my
relationship status sorry guys
is
single
and happy
and an independent parent is where you
can find me
the independent parent the dot
independent sorry yeah okay you get it
next do you go around to the other side
no you bro
okay i'm shay
um thanks for having me everyone um
obviously paul and stephen
i'm single
businessman
ready to hear to just tell my story
really
i just leave it there
hi everyone my name is suhaila um you
can find me at heyhayla on instagram and
my relationship status is minding my
business
[Laughter]
i'm next um i'm jess you can find me on
instagram it's your girl jess it's a dot
girl underscore underscore just and then
you can find me on youtube as well at
it's your girl jess and my relationship
status is single singled as a pringle
everyone's single here yeah
all right cool so if we get started
guys and girls
should men
record themselves
to protect themselves from the women of
this modern generation
um i'll start going good um i i think
they should but
like
the part that i can't get around is do
do they tell the girl that to they're
they're recording
because i i have a problem with
the idea of guys just like recording
girls and them not knowing
but at the same time
but are you going to be yourself
i know that's the thing i don't know i
can't record it i can see both sides
that's the hard part
because but i could see i could
definitely see like
recording like consent because
girls are crazy nowadays they might say
something happened when it did it just
just talk well
oh i should just oh yeah you don't need
to put your hand up
okay
um
i was speaking to them yeah i was going
to basically say obviously it become
it's all within reason
because um and depends on serious it is
because what a flip side here is if if
it was the other way if it was have a
situation and a man was being violent
towards a woman
that question even wouldn't be asked and
a
a lot would have come of it if the man
was abusive or aggressive or
um violent towards the partner towards
the woman
so again the question even wouldn't be
asked i thought we were talking about
like sex that's what i thought you meant
when you were recording oh so
if abuse oh my god yeah you should
record no but the thing is it's in both
instances i would say
that sex also can come into that and
also just interactions
generally whether it be like volatile or
whatever
i don't think anyone should record
anyone during sex without consent i
think it's wrong
um especially when you don't know what
the person's going to do with it i just
don't get that point
yeah why would you do that why would you
feel to do that um
good question i'll tell you why
have you guys heard of a book called how
to destroy a man
yes
so there's a book called how to destroy
a man you can find it on amazon and i'll
read the synopsis it says
want to destroy a man's reputation and
remove him from power
for misconduct this handbook by angela
confidential tells you how
in how to destroy a man
angela confidential empowers women with
a step-by-step guide for ruining a man's
reputation and removing him from
positions of power
and in easy to understand terms the
handbook reveals and explains the
fundamental dynamics between allegations
the media and authority as they relate
to male misconduct in today's society it
also unveils and details practical
real-world methods for leveraging
allegations media and authorities to
dethrone a man so she's the mr she's a
misandrist if we're gonna is that a
i'm just saying if there's a handbook
out there
on how to destroy a man shouldn't men
protect themselves i mean everything's
within reason isn't it so if you're a
reverse person that you feel that you
have to do that maybe then you shouldn't
be with that person so
i mean it's a long road to go through
you know it's it's
there's a lot of people say a lot of the
time but it's if you're seeing red flags
so if you're gonna get to that position
i wouldn't even go down that road but
it's interesting that he's out there
because obviously some people
out there know about that without even
reading that book
well i mean did you hear about that
there was a college case in the u.s
um and i can't remember what school it
was but basically the girl had a i'm
gonna use the word grape allegation
um
against this guy and basically said he
like came on to her and the only reason
that
he
um
yeah the only reason he got out of this
was because there was a video of them at
the bar
and she was like literally pulling him
back to the dorm
and it and then when they got to the
dorm like there's video of her like
enthusiastically like making out with
him and all this stuff
and if they didn't have that video
footage
the guy probably would have gotten
kicked out of school
as i'm saying it's a harsh one isn't it
because
the reality is it's not always the case
but if it is the case it's
understandable
so so
i think that
um
based off of what you just said it made
me think
that
men so your original question was should
they ask
no should they just record yes i think
for their own protection i think they
should record because in today's society
what the woman says
it rarely gets questioned
and so
in in a lot of legal cases it's either
it's the woman's word against the man's
word and so they can say
in that situation there was no videos
she would have got away with it
in
johnny depp's situation if we never
would have those videos it may have went
the other way may have went the same way
but i think that
men should do it because of the way
society is it sucks that is that way
that
women not all the time obviously there's
some women that abuse the system some
women that don't but
there's just
women's words against men words so
guess this is in the chat there's a
student who's the student still got
kicked out even after he showed video
proof that the allegations were false oh
wow wow you like you wouldn't say
something creative i just i just wanted
to say okay so
when it comes to
women being believed all the time i
don't agree with this um
i'm a woman that was not believed i had
recordings
i had recordings of him saying he raped
me
making fun of it mocking it
and um
i sent it i gave it to who i needed to
give it to and they still claimed it was
not enough evidence because it didn't
have his face in it
even though it was from his phone number
you could hear his voice you knew it was
him
it was still deemed not enough so as
much as we say that
oh when a woman says it oh it's
automatically true
that's not the case
so but i think do you think that that's
because of who you are
versus versus if you're a celebrity or
someone of status or maybe
if you were white or other ethnic group
you might have been believed i think
that um
obviously this my case was to do with
coercive control and behavior and it's
really really hard to prove
so
what's something that i saw after
coercive controlling what does that mean
so it's basically controlling someone
physically emotionally sexually
emotionally
and financially
um
i thought i thought there's one more but
i can't remember it right now um
mentally yes mentally as well psychology
yeah it's also yeah psychologically if
you if a person can damage you
psychologically to that point then it is
coercive controlling behavior
and
something that really really pissed me
off
after the case was dismissed
i saw that katie price
had um
won a case of coercive control and
behavior towards her i don't know
ex-boyfriend husband whoever it was one
of her partners and it really irritated
me because it was like it's only because
it's her
and then a few months later maybe a
couple weeks later i heard a story about
how she was caught drink or drug driving
or some kind of nonsense so it just
didn't make sense just because she's a
celebrity
you will send her ex-partner to prison
or um convict him of something but when
there's real people actually out here
doing this kind of [ __ ] excuse my
language um
we're not believed
i don't think it's like necessarily that
they don't believe you but i i just
think in a court case it has to be
innocent until proven guilty 100 and i
and it's very um tough to convict
someone of anything because of that but
that's that's the issue there was so
many different pieces when it comes to
domestic abuse itself
you can't just get evidence
it's like you're saying men should
record themselves right i agree record
record record everybody should record
but when that camera goes on when that
recording goes on and they know it's
going on they are not going to behave in
the way that they work
which is why i'm asking a question but i
think i think jess's point when she's
talking about like women automatically
being believed um i think what she means
is like in the media when a girl comes
forward and says something happened
um especially a couple years ago like
people automatically just took the
woman's side and in this case like amber
heard got an op-ed
um but without any evidence
and to me that's like insane
yeah so i think that's when that's
basically what i'm saying
what i'm sorry i feel like for me the
media doesn't it doesn't matter and when
i say the media i'm saying like
celebrities are going to do whatever
they do but when it comes to real people
why is it that when it comes to
celebrities oh they believe straight
away but then it's when it's real people
it's like oh it's not enough i don't
know
see i think that like women are actually
believed right away in real life too
like i think a girl can ruin a man's
reputation on a campus and immediately
people take her side
like regardless of if she if she's shown
them the evidence so i like i think if i
if i went to my team and i said
something happened to me and i said it
was that person on this team or
something like that like they would
automatically believe me because i'm
because i'm a woman yeah i think and and
i could ruin someone's reputation so i
know celebrities may be like seem out of
the ordinary but the issue is that if
this happened to a man with power money
and influence how many men did this
happen to across the country
now what i was going to say is that what
also you've got to realize is that
i think what it is it's generally
speaking so
it's not even a celebrity thing you on
in real life you do see a lot of as
steven said even i'm actually
you know an example of this so i know
that
women are believed
but um
in terms of the situation it i am
surprised as to i wonder why they didn't
because there might be just other
reasons as to what he may have been
saying and as i said they might have
been a tussle but generally speaking
as it's it's been seen women are more
believed than men in that situation i
wasn't in the room in his interview i
don't know what his interview said i
don't know what he was asking i have no
idea but what i do know is
that
um
he knew he could get away with it
and that is exactly what happened he
also did other things after the fact
that they also completely ignored
someone sitting outside your house for
two years
and then them not checking the cctv i
think anyway in the uk the police force
let me not even them not even go there
but um
in terms of like women being believed i
feel like
in the reality especially in this
country there are women that have had
evidence
and have spoken up
and they are not listened to to the
point where it becomes
detrimental there are women that have
actually passed away because of not
being listened to so it's not about not
being believed they're believed but it's
kind of like
oh there's not much we can do about it
there's not much we can do about it
until it becomes really really bad well
just you know what that is i couldn't
even answer that but i think if we look
at casey's just in general across the
board i think it just depends on the
police the police force the police the
area you live
i just say where you are in the state
it's le and on the status level so it
just all depends because unfortunately
we hear that all the time you hear every
day in the news like you could hear
someone talking about oh they knew that
was a suicide bomber that's come to the
house it'd be report social service even
an example saying someone's been doing
whatever to children whatever it is you
always find that there's people that
negligent um in terms of their
professional
professionalism and that's actually what
just happens he says unfortunately you
might just get a or i might
get a bad bad
unprofessional person and i think that's
just unfortunate how it is did you know
in most domestic violence cases both
parties are abusing each other
and in one-sided abuse cases um
the
woman actually abuses the man like one
side of meaning it's not retaliated
um the woman abuses the man 70 percent
of the time
absolutely and i think there's a
misconception that women are weak
when it comes to domestic violence i
feel that
you know people assume the man's
stronger he could have done this he
could have done that and then when you
look at the acts of violence against men
it's more
not to say more malicious but the the
tactics used are more manipulative and
they can have impact on the man that
maybe he won't talk about it for a long
time
do you get what i mean so when we're
talking about domestic violence against
men
it's a different kettle of fish in the
way they're being abused
i feel like with women they can say oh
he hit me or he punched me and people
take action
where is he so
when it comes to abusive i was just
looking uh because i've got a website
for um it's called domestic abuse
the national center for domestic abuse
and he's talking about male domestic
abuse and it says
the organization reports that 95 of its
callers suffer emotional abuse these are
men
right so men suffer 95 emotional abuse
68 percent is physical
41 is psychological 23 is financial
13 is coercive control and 3
is sexual abuse
towards men
like when men suffer from domestic
violence
i can believe that emotional abuse for
men
it they don't talk about their emotions
in general and i think that when men say
they're being emotionally abused what
what is the line where do what do we
look at
i think what it is is that even
interesting
just being on this podcast
and as a man you automatically know that
it's not something you're meant to talk
about yeah where women are because of
being emotionally they're allowed to
speak on it so i already know
that you you if you could picture the
comments
you know as men you know if you go and
speak about these things
it's actually like these words like simp
and look at this one like we talking
about blah blah so that's why it's like
man up and you know to some degree i get
it
but the thing is something you said
which is important just now is that
someone i wish there was there's a word
there's a term i need to find it but
it's actually where that's used it's
very manipulative where because it was
happened to me i was i was actually
personally told no one would believe you
but that that thing where because you're
the stronger you're the physical it's
that that's the license that you can hit
me attack me say whatever you say to me
because we're the physically stronger
and even true to social service and this
is what i was saying to you earlier
about depends on who are professionals
because it's not all because i had some
professional social workers that gave me
good advice but one even when she was
telling me she said to me oh don't worry
about it
don't worry about ignore that like
ignore it you wouldn't say that but
again it's because
you know sometimes it's even
subconscious because i guess a lot of
women have gone through a lot of things
it's not normal for them to come and
hear a man speak about things like this
because men don't come forward the only
reason i even come for because it
regarded my daughter if it wasn't that
you know you would walk away because
that wasn't the issue but when your
child is being used as a porn that's
when it's an issue
is that also part of the the abuse that
you think that men ha that men suffer
from like when women use children
against oh i said yeah i think that's
one of the key factors and with children
involved you can have a big impact on a
man's emotions and it affects his mental
health his physical health the way he
perceives himself in the world
so
for him there are sorry guys
for him um i think when
you're using his children as a
um
it
you know
he's in a position where he has to
choose between himself and his children
and a lot of people don't understand
that so can you
just okay so with my ex-partner i've
completely cut contact
simply because
when everything happened you've attacked
me in front of my kids and then you ran
away
fine
case happened all of that i've given you
options was that recorded what with the
yes yes
in front of your children that was what
was recorded it wasn't visually recorded
it was audio said to him so many times
get out of my house or i'm going to call
the police said it about three times and
on the third time i ran out of the house
i called the police he had me in a
headlock in front of the kids he was
hitting me in front of them and usually
what was frustrating was he wouldn't do
that in front of them he would do in the
bedroom
and then when they come towards the
bedroom it's like oh look look what your
mom's doing but then in this instant
because it was over money
it was like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
gonna do it in front of my kids whether
they're there or not so when i did call
them and i gave them everything when
they gave him nfa and whatever it was it
was as if like
he he taunted me for about two years he
taunted me sat outside my house watching
me i reported all of these things and
they literally said there's not enough
evidence so
even with the recording you could hear
he's hitting me you could hear he like
it wasn't
i don't understand why someone would
make that up with their children in
their presence my son still remembers
this the thing is the thing is you say
that why would somebody make that up but
it's the same thing as why would amber
heard make it up fair enough do you get
what i'm saying it's like we don't i
think people in this society
um there's a lot of people with i don't
know undiagnosed mental issues do you
know what i mean and so when people
people put themselves in positions that
they shouldn't be in because that's what
i wouldn't do it well you're not them
saying like because they have a totally
different actually gonna say i was gonna
say what she was saying about um
how men feel when the children are used
so he would turn around and say to
people that i'm using the children
against him
and i'm stopping him from seeing the
children i've given you the option of
going to court i've given you the option
of going to mediation
i've even said come and meet me in the
holidays
in an open space in public
whereby you can see the children
obviously he didn't know but i had a
security guard come in simply for my own
safety he still would not agree to it
but he wanted me to come and meet him
to argue to fight
to chase on the road which is ridiculous
but he wouldn't actually come to see the
children so when people say like oh
you're using the children as a pawn it's
confusing to me because i'm giving you
all the options there
but i don't know that's the thing is
sorry
in other words
i don't think that um they're talking
about cases where like the guy won't see
the kids and is using like that like i
think that's like your case but when
we're talking about people using kids as
pawns what we're talking about is cases
where the mom won't let the dad see the
kids and that the dad has to go to
school spends thousands of dollars on a
lawyer begging to see the children he
will say that i'm not letting him see
that right
but you're making it very personal yeah
but no no not not personal but i'm
saying in the sense of like there are
some men
that will talk the talk and not do what
they're supposed to do to me
i mean yeah yeah i mean yeah no i agree
like they're they're like like there are
guys that do that but what i'm talking
about is the guys that like their guys
that go to court spend thousands of
dollars and spend years trying to fight
for their kids in court and just one day
give up because
they're dead broke they've been fighting
for for like for those guys that commit
suicide over this yeah um i would just
say that according to uk statistics uh
200
men per day according to fathers for
justice
are removed from their child's life
and the suicide rate for men that have
been removed for their child's life is
i think
up a third within father's
you said 200 a day 200 a day wow
it's it's even interesting i think are
you talking about money because that's
my case right there i mean
i've
mentioned this before on the podcast but
i've spent over i say 25k
to see my daughter and i think the only
reason i didn't get the situation where
i had to give up because in a funny way
that mother still wanted her space
because i felt like
my daughter was a
at that point was a liability not even
just a life like a burden because that's
what i would say
it was like a burden to her so at the
same time she wanted her space so she
knew that i would want to see her so
that's what the games would play so with
my situation when i didn't
allowed to see my daughter for three
months
and all that money i spent when i did go
to court my barristers actually said wow
this is the first they've seen an
experience where a woman's made all this
up and then now we've gone to court
she's now allowing me access wait did
not ask are you saying you spent 25k in
three months and to know because um
it's like within my case with say from
29 to 20 21 it's about 25k i spent
overall speaking to the market yeah so
it's a bit overruled i spent about 10k
due into thinking but again like i said
it's not about the money but again it is
about the money if
you ain't got that you're not in that
position because as you said some guys
would just be spending i was willing to
keep going because i knew and this is
why i i think in terms of what you said
about all the recordings what's
interesting
when i was giving stuff things to
certain
social services i was actually saying to
myself they must not have seen it and
remember a lot of this is time consuming
for them so what happened so are you
saying that you had to record so yeah
that i'm going to get to that okay so
sorry so
in terms of recording everything where
you're meant you're believing that
they're actually seeing it we actually
don't know after they see because
there's a lot of time there's a lot of
serious more things happening
and yours ain't good enough or serious
enough sorry i'm for like myself talking
to them so like myself but then there
would be time because persistent and
then there was continued things in there
to say hang on
now this is what i'm going to look at
and that's basically what brought my
case even more forward so what kind of
things did you have to record well
because of my situation like i said i
there was so much times i would say your
violent behavior your abusive behavior
towards me and the children because she
had another she had a son as well and i
continuously said can you please
stop you know behaving in a certain way
but what hadn't happened a situation
where she then said i punched her in the
eye and i thought wow
this is deep now you're going to say a
punch die in my head i just said i
wouldn't put cam camera surveillance in
the house so i set up camera
surveillance in the house i wanted it in
her son's room because i know she'd
abuse her son a lot and i'd i re he
reached out to me many times and liked
to come get him out of that house
and um
in the front room in the bedroom because
this is when a lot of times would take
place so what i had to do was put
cameras in the house to protect myself
did she know about the camera of course
not because then she wouldn't know if
this is the thing no she didn't know so
in terms of this is why i said it's an
interesting situation because the thing
is that it worked against me and then it
worked for me because at the day what
she was actually saying
i handed over to her social uh her her
solicitors so her listeners could see
her abusive behaviors the social
services could see her abusive behaviors
and people around that
may have thought i was lying
the evidence was there because i'd
noticed that i then got to know that i
was not the only man because she had
done it to a previous
partner before that he had actually
recordings of her abusive behavior
so um
so that's why i'm saying that it was
interesting even though that protected
me if it was the other way around it
would have just that would have been a
straight charge sheet
but that's what i'm trying to say that
it's not that's what that's why i said
generally speaking yeah because even
though you're saying you're sick
so i know your circumstances
unfortunately as you've got all the
evidence but there's a lot of women and
there's a lot of men i know that even
come to my meetings that are not seeing
their children are having problems
because women have made allegations see
me i'd be happy for him to see his kids
i don't mind just as long as it was safe
maybe you need to go to another
police or whoever you're dealing with if
they're not professional enough you need
to go to somewhere else because it seems
like you're banging on her i've spoken
to the minister of safeguarding
again
is is it because it wasn't on video yeah
because it was audio yeah because it
could have just been because mine was
video yeah see mine was video definitely
wasn't a doorstep
i i know i i believe you yeah but i'm
saying like like just from a legal
perspective it's innocent until proven
guilty well this is why i'm asking the
question whether we should start reading
yeah that's what i was going to say as
well i feel like everybody should record
yeah that's fine but the thing is once
people start recording and recording
each other it becomes a battle
when one person is recording they're
acting like they're innocent because i'm
not going to sit here and say that i was
completely innocent the whole time i did
things that were not great
in reaction when you've taken
six to eight years of abuse you end up
reacting you defend yourself
right
but it will be made to seem as if
i'm
behaving
but that's what the thing is that's why
domesticate that's why even police when
they come to the dhonies happens they
don't really tend to want to do it
remember any day as a professional it's
very hard because you just said it
yourself you just kind of i feel like
you've admitted that you've done certain
things so i admitted it to them i told
them every single thing but i'm not
ashamed of it i know but what i'm saying
is that if all their sin remember
they're not emotionally as i said
someone said that it's personal to you
if he's hit you've if he's hit you 50
and you've hit him 10 times they just
see it's hitting so you're both issues
you both need to how they look at it
like how the court looks at you have to
look at through the child stop doing it
mediation do this now they don't really
want to hear the back and forth exactly
which is what so speaking to them so
yeah they don't want to hear the back
and forth so unfortunately i can feel
that pain
but as as a professional they cut that
out it's about the child what you're
going to do mediation dish blah blah
blah so i get what you're saying but
that's just how it is
i have a question for the panel um do
you guys
think that society
and or men have a duty to protect women
yes
they have a duty to protect women
who they're involved with who are in
their family
in the general space i believe that men
should protect women and i don't know
what you mean by protect does it
physically protect them or what is
protect
it depends on the scenario
um i don't know it was a super chat and
i just thought it was a good question
yeah it's just very general because if
you're a protective woman who's getting
i'm attacked across the and i can see
here i think
instinctively as a
male as myself because it's not all
males i would it's just my nature i've
got sisters mothers so when i see that
that instinct in me that i will protect
so it depends on the circumstance
i think that um
i don't think it should be a
men should protect women i think humans
should protect each other
and that should be how it is when i say
human should protect each other a man
may protect physically a woman may
protect emotionally so
there's different forms of protecting so
you can't just say oh because he's a man
and because he's physically strong oh he
should he should be in charge of
protecting a woman can also protect too
it's just
how
that makes sense the nature of the
question so men protecting women what
does that entail
what does it entail i think it just
means like society at large like if a
woman's getting attacked should then
protect her
um
but then we'll probably
you would try to protect that person i
guess
it depends on the context of the attack
do you get what i mean so
if i saw a woman getting attacked on the
street and i could do something i'll be
like what's going on like i might jump
in
but then
if it's someone with a gun
how what would i be able to do am i
risking my life
some questions are very like it needs
context
general questions well i think so the
point of this one was like if if men
should to protect women in general then
how can society do that while treating
them as equal to men
i like that
can you repeat that again please so if
men should protect women in general like
if men invite like if there's a plane
crashing right or like um
the plane that crashed into the hudson
or the titanic they always take the
women and the children to go off first
so by and large in a lot of situations
they say men should protect women
so if that's true
then how should society treat them as an
equal to men
there you go
there you go um what did bill burr say
billboard said there's a reason why men
get paid more even though they don't but
he was making a joke yeah he was saying
there's a reason why men get paid more
do
they don't the wage gap is a whole thing
but the reason why they they should be
paid more
is because of that
if something goes down you're looking to
us to do the thing you ain't doing it if
the house starts burning down now you're
waiting for a fireman or a fire woman
who are you waiting on okay but then if
you say men should speak into them
if you say men should be paid more i'm
not saying that it was a joke that bill
bernie said gilbert whoever it was said
that men should be paid more
then shouldn't women also be paid
enough when i say enough because if
you're protecting them are we talking
about a non-joke and real society now
i'm talking about let's mix it a little
bit okay so real society like let's just
say like
the man is protecting the woman from the
titanic he dies
god forbid but
um it happened and now the woman is left
to look after the child
and the family and whoever else is left
behind that the man was responsible for
why should she not be paid enough it
then becomes more difficult
for her to provide for that child and
whoever else it's because women don't
choose hard jobs
that's exceptional it's the exception
rather than the rule if you look at
plumbers electricians
garbage men it's the men and so if
you're going to do a harder job you're
going to get paid more
yeah
do you want to go do you want to work
you want to go work in a uric in the
middle of the atlantic ocean exactly
just by that i don't i doubt rose that's
what marriage i think that's what
marriage came into as a business and
that's why when there's a marriage and
if you break up that's where women then
start collecting isn't it
because of this situation that's why the
marriage is correct was correct why do
men get upset when the women collect no
no who's sitting now you're generalizing
yeah i feel like okay no depending on
what if you've got my children when you
say when you say women collect what are
they collecting what you mean
the bag like life insurance no like
after the divorce
marriage has well the richest women in
america are divorcees so look i didn't
know
it's the relationship
people co-parent well and if you ever
respect with each other naturally you're
going to want to do well for do but good
goodbye then unfortunately there are
those toxic ones isn't it do you guys
think right that
men have become more abused
yes
because they've been weakened so they're
not allowed to be men in their in their
own position that's
i know you're shaking your head but
there are certain things that men have
always done or do within their circles
and for some reason i feel like women
are trying to infiltrate that and kind
of say oh if you behave like this you're
not you're not a real man it's the
modern society we shouldn't do these
things and i think that there's things
that we don't really understand as women
because we're on a different plane
we are
we're equal but we're different
and
thank you but we need to respect each
other's differences
so that we can work together rather than
want the same things and say
okay well he's doing that so why can't i
yeah actually principally we're
different
so we sit in different places but
together we create
a beautiful
i think that's what the issue is oh
sorry no i was just someone said going
off of that i heard somebody say on
the last podcast last week that um
men and women
aren't equal they're more like a yin and
a yang and it blew my mind i was like
that's so true because
you
as much as we want to say oh i don't
need a man i don't need a woman blah
blah blah you you need we need each
other to
exist in society
my personal opinion because we see a
different world now but yes i agree but
then if men are becoming more abused
nowadays
then we can see like
johnny depp
um we can see
and that's and i think sorry i just just
to kind of go somewhere else but i think
abuse isn't just physical as we already
said like what happened this year is is
drake
had to put hot sauce in his condom
right
to stop himself to stop a woman
getting pregnant by him yeah that he
didn't want right yeah right and so
that's a form of abuse i don't know
about it
but really ask the question why are you
sleeping with that woman yeah yeah yeah
yeah nobody was that allowed why would
you if you could if you
speak one at a time speaking to the mic
please just the question
if you sleep with someone and you feel
that you have to put hot sauce
in your condom why are you sleeping but
the question is i just don't think women
face consequences i think that's why
like men are more abused because we
don't we don't face consequences for
doing it and just like this that's not
illegal for a girl to take a condom
and you might be like why would you
sleep with a girl like that but as a guy
he's a lottery ticket for a woman
so even even though he knows that though
he knows
his position
and i think as a man when you're a catch
or a prize man you have the pick of the
letter you can choose anybody so should
he say celibate
yes he will he has not stopped no stop
your narcissism
as a man you should be disciplined and a
disciplined man can get far in life and
he doesn't he has to deal with a lot of
things he has to deal with a lot of
things and this is the problem she's not
so funny
this generation they kind of lack
discipline when it comes to certain
behaviors you say
you don't understand a man's nature you
know for you to say that you don't
really understand a man's nature because
um yeah
when men like general now this is
generally like no i'm saying generally a
man's nature yeah is to have sex yes
it's general nature but the thing is
when you get put in a position of power
you as a woman would have no idea
the amount of women that are coming for
that man of power as a matter of fact
tiger woods can be married all married
men regardless of how much power they
hold they've got a bunch of women that
are just looking to have sex with that
man and so men
being men yeah in positions of power
sometimes
they say okay i'll take the option it
doesn't mean because you took the option
that you now have to have um in these
days and times you now have to have a
baby yeah
well but he was he was responsible too
right he used a condom he wore a condom
and and why why are we putting this on
the women around the med why don't we
put this on the women why are we acting
like home so like where are we why are
we acting like hoes why are you sleeping
right so basically what it is because
you're confused by the thing so
basically he obviously ejaculated in the
condom but afterwards he put hot sauce
in there to basically kill the sperm and
then threw it in the trash but the woman
went in the trash
took a condom out and tried to push it
inside of her and burnt up her thing and
had he not done that she would have had
a baby by him and he would have said if
you if you play it out nine months down
the line he would have said there's no
way that woman's pregnant for my bit for
with my baby because i use a condom
however
once she done the dna test it would have
had his dna and they would have said
drake you're talking lies because the
bottom line is she's got your dna but so
he would have looked like the liar yeah
so
you guys do not think sorry but do you
guys think that because we had a
conversation the other day was saying
like women like to fight for social
justice right and eventually that helps
to change laws why do men not stand up
when things are happening to them and
speak up about it and have those laws
changed it should be illegal for a woman
to take a condom and shove it up herself
and have a baby it should be
maybe it's because it's hard to prove
yeah
[Laughter]
as women it's
it's innate in us for us to be able to
talk about
whatever it is you can sit around and
talk about someone you
talk about something with someone you've
known for maybe an hour five minutes
however it is as for men
it's not innate in them to be able to
sit down with their friends like hey yo
this this this this because
it's just
i don't i don't know it's just something
that has been
just shown like oh mention shouldn't
talk mention and talk about this mention
and gossip like women around the table
but they do though in private men have
real conversations with their boys about
the women that they're engaging with or
do you know her oh i'm talking to this
girl blah blah they want their friends
opinions as well because if they're
dating a girl or linking her imagine
your boys are saying oh that girl's
clapped or she's nasty or whatever but
that's different from that's different
from talking about issues a lot of men
don't talk about the issues that they
have they can talk about females all day
talk about working out this that in the
third second no you know jesse's right
because i went to a
it was called
mantle actually it was in brixton
and i remember those
some professionals up there and they
were discussing about men issues
and it was only till i talked about my
issue
of
the mother not allowed me to see my
daughter
the whole energy changed in the room and
there was other men that came up and
started speaking even the two of the
panels that was talking about other
addictions and other issues that they
had didn't feed it upon themselves to
talk about how they ain't seen their
child or the
parental alienation they were facing so
you're writing the zack in terms of what
jessica just said it's i've noticed even
from the back of as i said my podcast
and people have seen
a lot of fathers have reached out to me
that i've been surprised and so wow i've
been going through this and they've
wanted to know what things to do
to actually start to see their children
it's you know what it's really deep um
it's a serious subject so i really again
have to say i appreciate
your poem you know sort of talking on it
you know what's interesting so
when i talk about a situation where the
woman is completely in the wrong right
there there's we no one on this panel
would say that the girl with the hot
sauce situation was in the right like we
all agree she was wrong
but we automatically put the blame onto
men and we say oh well you shouldn't be
dealing with that but earlier when she
was talking about a situation
where she was in it like like he was
completely in the wrong nobody says oh
well you shouldn't have been dealing
with him
exactly can i pause but yeah when i went
on the podcast
the amount of disgusting comments
that were written under that podcast i
was told that um
god is going to punish me and i chose to
open my legs and just all these
different things i chose the wrong man i
wanted this person that was like this
and
and xyz without actually understanding
the layers of the situation when i met
this person
i was 16. he was a good eight years
older than me
that in itself does not tell you
something
but for whatever reason i was getting
all these comments online at me
that
and again it comes to this whole
protection aspect the way i looked at it
was i was 16 and young and i was
in a situation where i felt like he was
protecting me really
he took advantage of the situation and
that is what led on to whatever happened
over the years but when i went on the
podcast what i found quite disappointing
was the fact that
i was attacked online and not many
people in the comments stood up for me
and this is the issue i feel like when
women do come out and speak
so
it's okay for celebrities to speak but
when real people speak
it's like a oh my gosh well you should
have seen the red flags and you should
have done this and you should have done
that well i i i think it's just like a
level of accountability you know like
like the same way we were holding like
the manic like like to me that that's
the same but i don't think that's the
norm i mean can i add
just to say when you were speaking you
said you know you said celebrities and
then real people and that that concept
in people's mind that's what it is they
separate celebrities from real people so
when i said about drake
the reasons i said that is because he
already had a child in those similar
circumstances do you get what i mean so
him still um
putting himself in a position with oh no
we put the hot sauce yeah you need to
cheese
i get that but you still but the thing
is regardless of hot sauce or not you're
putting yourself in that position
furthermore the fact that the media has
it to talk about you're putting ideas in
people's head you're actually putting
the idea out into the effort okay and i
find that why i should do that yeah i
think that a lot of these behaviors that
we're seeing with young women in
young women and men is it's coming from
the fact that the media kind of projects
it into the space and circulates it on a
crazy hyper basis but can you imagine
the level of
paranoia
you have to be going through
every time you have sex as drake to
think damn did i put the hot sauce on a
condom this time do you know what i mean
and i think it's unfortunate that the
times in which we live in going back to
the book that i actually said talking
about how to destroy a man
whether or not
the fact that that book exists
i don't know how many women have read it
you don't know how many women have read
it
ish doesn't know how many people have
read it like we just don't know how many
women have read it so it's like is it
now time to protect ourselves well
you know what i think would stop a lot
of this if men could do a financial
abortion
women women have the right not to be a
parent
so so i think like a lot of these girls
are doing this because they're trying to
get a check
if so if that happened if there was a
financial abortion sorry speaking to
them
imagine if men could say right yes i had
sex with this woman but i don't want to
be responsible for the child if there
becomes a child how many more single
parents would they well women do that
they say i yes i hooked up with this man
but i don't want to be a mom i'm going
to kill it
they can do that up to six months
it's truly true
so if we can if we can do that then [ __ ]
then he should be able to do the same
thing
but the man and we shouldn't be doing it
they're already doing it yeah but but
that's what they're saying but the man
do you control having the child or not
so he can't do it he might get you
pregnant but you have the power to
exactly no i don't believe in that
statement i don't believe men get women
pregnant know what i mean when i get
pregnant no absolutely 100 the fault of
the woman if you get pregnant if you get
pregnant that's on you as a woman 100
man
so i'll tell you how i'll explain how
i'll explain how so
the first time i heard that i was like
what do you mean but if you think about
it
who knows
when you're like the time that you're
fertile
yeah the woman does
who gets
sorry
it's your job if you if you don't want
to get pregnant if you don't want to um
if you don't want to get pregnant period
is your job to voice that to the man
and then if he and certain obviously in
certain situations there's
there's things that happen to where
a woman gets pregnant and
it wasn't it was just a message like
this
every woman is head of security for
their own vagina
every woman is head of security right
and the only the only if it's not a
great situation
you let somebody in
just like there's a door here
if it's not a burglar situation
someone let someone into this place and
hang on and hang on and the
responsibility for letting if you didn't
vet the person properly or if they
didn't show their id and you believed it
you look at the heidi that's on you
because once they run up in your house
and burgle your house that's going to be
on you
you have to be hang on but no but you
have to be
head of security for your own vagina and
so if you keep letting men who are not
worthy up into your vagina and shooting
up your club that's your that's on you
iuds are more than 99 effective
get an ied
yeah but then someone will argue not me
per se but someone will argue oh that
affects my hormones that affects my hair
okay then go down and then so does a
baby yeah
baby affects your whole life
you know like sometimes the fats are fat
one at a time one at a time
an iud or whatever hormones you're
putting into your body affect your body
and that can affect you later on in life
than having a child
that with the wrong person in a single
parent home yeah i would pick the iud i
have two children with a very wrong
person but i love my children
to the deaf of me and maybe not to the
deaf but i mean i love my children okay
and i think they're amazing people and
i'm grateful that i have the opportunity
to actually
raise my children in a different way and
some people may not agree with me
stopping contact but that is what i have
to do to be able to do that
and
i would rather have my children now
than be bleeding for the rest of my life
and in pain
and having possibly other complications
in my body
just so that somebody
could well we're talking about
accidental pregnancy i'm not talking
about
like the guy the choice between a guy
beating you and like
yeah talking about the beat yeah but
even even the
actual having the child obviously it's
come from
um non-protected sex right so my point
is
i could have been protected and as well
it's like does that not show you how men
can be coercively abusive in the sense
of how many men have said how many men
have said let me just put a tip in
and they keep going
no i mean i'm saying like that was a
choice like you don't have to deal with
those guys
so
so
i'm saying like that's a choice you
don't have to deal with those guys like
so so that that's a personal choice
and and another thing as well you see
you just you've just said it there
you're still in control that
understanding of circumstance you're in
control if he sees the children or not
if it was the other way around this is
why we this conversation we're having
today if you was like that
you're still in control
so we don't have the control of having
our own children when we want to see
them yeah but he also has control no one
has control in the sense of if you want
to see your children
you go
to the court no but if he doesn't but
you don't have to look into the mic
sorry but this is my point right there
and you see because i know your
circumstance and what he's done i don't
know so i can only believe what you
don't actually know
what she told you yeah yeah exactly
that's why i can only believe what
you're saying
no no you don't even have to because i'm
just saying
based on what you're saying you're
saying he can go all of that is a
process i've had to wait months to go to
cool and all that mental and time
it affects your psyche and depending on
what kind of person it is so it's like
all you gotta do is that's a lot in
itself those children are still sitting
at home with you
no but again
so many options it wasn't just the
process no no no i heard you clearly i'm
saying i get what you're saying you're
not one of them ladies trying to not let
him sing he's been abused i heard that
but what i'm saying is that what we
everyone's disc what the discussion is
is that you see because it's on the
man's side of things this is not
discussed about misanji and our parental
alienation our women because obviously
the men awaits the deadbeats if the
women sit around in the room until he
don't do this he don't pay women will be
like yeah yeah jonah said no generally
speaking because it's not a woman so
what i'm saying it's until when a man
come and speaks about it so oh he's
actually doing more than just being a
weekend father do you know what i mean
so that's what it is i rate the men that
are like that
so much because at least you're fighting
for your child but not every man can
fight
not every man wants to fight
women i have to fight for their children
but at the end of the day for your child
you will fight i'm fighting for my
children
i'm protecting them no but they mean i
get you you protect them in the home but
you're not fighting
against someone taking them from you
you're as a mother instinctively you
love you and and cherish your children
and nurture them technically i am
because he's threatened to and he has
tried to okay yeah but the thing is of
you yeah i'm just saying you keep making
it so personal we're trying to talk
general
like
we're not saying that your situations
don't exist we're just saying that you
know generally yeah when men are
fighting for their children they have a
certain threshold when men are fighting
for something that they love they have a
certain threshold even if it's with a
woman after fighting for a woman for
solomon you know what forget about it
i'm not doing it right so it's the same
with children it's not the fact that
they don't want to see their children
it's a fact that they're in a situation
where they're not willing to fight
anymore and when it comes to that
women need to understand that every man
has their limits so if you push the man
to the limit and then he says well you
know what don't worry about it then
she'll go around saying oh he's a
deadbeat dad it's like no hang on he
wasn't actually a deadbeat dad he
actually wanted to fight for his
children you i'm not talking about you
but you as a woman made it so hard for
him to see his child that he said you
know what
keep him you know i can agree with that
because there are some women where say
for example their children are taken
away because they have neglected them or
they've abused them or whatever it is
and they have the option to do the right
thing to get the children back they
don't fight they go out they go out
raven they go out smoking drinking
whatever it is and they don't do enough
to get their children back so i do get
what you're saying and even in that
enough to have their children in the
first place if that's the case so we
have to look at sorry
no no no no you're fine
you know when you look at
relationships and children speaking to
them oh sorry looking at the partnership
in itself the foundation that
partnership is built on
if you look at most of these
relationships you realize that the
foundation was dodgy from the jump and i
think it's about mutual respect when
there's no mutual respect between
two individuals then there can never be
a solid partnership regardless of
children
a breakup whatever there's always
someone who's lacking from quite early
on you get one because yeah and it's
funny you said that because that's what
i'm saying about you saying about the
protecting how many mothers or how many
women you know that know that other
women abusive towards
their children like you don't hear much
women i don't hear it come out and talk
about
women
knowing that other women abuse their
children right and they will they'll be
the first to talk about abuse and
psychological abuse and all this in my
circumstances where i can talk honestly
and know clearly about it that women
won't come forward
about other women abuse in fact when you
even saw social look how much it takes
for them to remove a child yeah but why
they wouldn't do that
anonymously yeah but why they wouldn't
do that because then they would hold
them have to hold themselves accountable
for what they do because then they're in
acknowledging behaviors that they commit
to themselves so are we talking about
the other friends that so if a woman is
abusing a child
and another woman knows about it yeah
and she's co-signing or whatever
she has to acknowledge the part she
plays in allowing it to happen
or if she does it herself say like
they're agreeing they're both single
mothers slaying the father whatever they
she would have to acknowledge her part
playing that behavior herself yeah so
they join allegiance to not even join
allegiance
on both sides of the field i'm trying to
be fair here
it's about taking accountability for
your part to play in the problem
everybody can everybody can point their
fingers kind of point out the problem
but what is the solution
i've already said many times women only
women don't like other women generally
but the only time they do is when it's
time to go against men
when it's time to go against men you'll
get a bunch of them be like yeah men are
this blah blah but you take men at that
equation and then women are looking at
each other as competition they're
looking at your hair they're looking at
your nails they're looking at your shoes
they're looking at this and they're
looking at you as competition it's like
yeah
that's that's
it
i think that's that think that still
boils down to accountability because
when you look at say for example i could
acknowledge every woman in this room is
beautiful now if there's a man that i
like and i can see there's other women
that could potentially take him from me
in my eyes
it's natural to feel like boom like how
do i bolster myself up in that way do
you get what i mean so
no no i think every woman is different
it's not it's a natural response because
you like somebody or they they're your
partner maybe you feel like oh you know
the way my man is interacting with these
women it's a threat to me do you
understand what i'm saying so a lot of
women won't acknowledge that there's
other women in the room that are better
than them i can be in a room and i can
acknowledge there's women
that have qualities that i don't have
and when you acknowledge that you have
confidence in yourself
and that's what that normally makes
other women jealous and like yeah yeah
of course i want to sit here and say
that like oh say for example like what
you're saying there's a man in the room
will say it's my man and nobody might
know that he's not my man because i
won't necessarily show it i'm not that
type of girl me i'm just me and i'm just
there and that's that yeah but let's
just say like the guy was in the room
and other women are pushing up on him
no no no but it's internalized you don't
have to project it outwardly you feel it
and as a woman if you like a man or
you're with a man and you don't feel
protective over your man that's a bit of
i think there's a level guys hang on one
second okay yeah so we're gonna we're
gonna read super chats really exciting
um okay guys um
we got quite a few let me refresh the
page really quick
okay so we got
um dragon stallion 1001. women accused
an entire lacrosse team of gang graping
her everyone on campus believed her with
no proof she lied she ruined all of
their reputations and it turned out she
lied alan stranger women are more likely
to use weapons and dv a black dude got
stabbed by his wife in chicago and the
police show up and shot him instead
corey the the problem is the media and
feminism has
stretched what grape essay is so far
that it's no longer taken seriously
there are women that consider a cat call
grape or if she internally feels minor
discomfort
brian kirkland
do you think that men don't record
consent because it might make them feel
scared or weak also yellow shirt is a
great speaker
manny fresh question for the panel does
society men have a duty to protect or
safeguard women if so how can society
and men do that while treating them as
equal or or equal to men or do adults
have autonomy of their own body the
spoken one does society over protect
women even from the consequences of
their own actions info vader people need
to stop ignoring how different men and
women women are the only reason today's
topic is relevant is because of how
different we are the more you focus on
equal the worse your outcomes will be
the uk economist studies have shown that
most men are invisible to most women
it's but it's strange how in an
emergency those invisible men become
visible and are expected to put their
lives at risk to protect women
brandon jackson
same for women who give birth control
and get birth control contraception
should they sleep not sleep with guys
that they don't want to be the father of
their children
just human the mra has been fighting for
men's rights since the 90s and has been
demonized by the media as misogynistic
feminists had big campaigns against them
through most of the 2010s men speak up
but they aren't taken serious mr demark
this panel seems to be ignorant of the
many court cases around the world where
a woman has stolen sperm to get pregnant
and the man has lost them all
the just human child childbirth can be
fatal you know hormones might affect
your body but child birth might be fatal
the spoken one there was a man in the
u.s who split with his wife and had to
fight the courts for years he gets a new
girlfriend and she falls pregnant
and says she'll do the same thing he hit
his limit and ended up murdering and
self-deletion um doug mpa the 20 only 20
of the show has been on topic the rest
has been about the girl in the blue the
world owns no one understanding it's not
just about her
well damn welcome to the internet
welcome to the internet guys so
um
to get back to get back on topic as a
matter of fact um about the recording
i actually know um
a quote-unquote celebrity um not gonna
name names and that celebrity was
accused of grape
that celebrity was accused of grape once
and that celebrity
or that person
went to jail for a certain amount of
time for it
what that
person done after getting back out
is that they put camera recordings
or cameras sorry in their bedroom
and one day and he used to record he
said see women blah blah blah do you
know what i mean east sea women
and
one day he had sex with a woman
and then in a couple days she had
accused him of grape
again second time now
however the cameras
recorded the fact that he didn't do that
and he won his case
so
i know a lot of women
don't want to be recorded in their
intimate moments right
but the reason why i'm asking this
question is because of cases like this
cases like johnny um
how would you feel as a woman
being recorded without your consent like
that
just as long as he's not sharing it or
showing it to anybody
go for it we'll make a movie you can
record me go for it
but in that let me know
in that sense i don't
i think if it's for
like protection he should be able to
anybody should be able to record it just
in that case that it doesn't happen
again false allegations don't happen
again
like i said don't show anybody
yeah as long as it doesn't hit the
internet then it's fine because once it
hits the internet that woman can
technically now bring a case against you
for sharing pornographic images of her
about her without her consent and that's
her thing now
it's been a thing yeah i don't know
about it legally now
it's a real i mean that's what it should
be i mean we're mature now you know
you know before like early days of
internet people would get away with that
kind of thing now it's like yeah they
did because it's on the internet so
they'll say you it's in an open space
but if the person didn't consent to it
yeah but you have to prove it right yeah
but you could you can watch it and you
know you've got again the professionals
yeah you can look and see if that person
would sorry you can see and if that
person was aware they were being
recorded yeah yeah you know and then
lines i think now it's been recorded but
i'm filming right now there's actually i
think there's laura right now
oh welcome yeah time to change so yeah
maybe there should be consent to record
but
then there's consent to share if you say
you want to share it that's fine if you
say you don't want to share it and
that's your business no
i think there should be consent to share
it
but to record
i think if it's using like a court of
law and it hasn't been shared that
should be personally like i would never
want something recorded of me like out
there
you know like i just wouldn't want
someone to have the power to like
have that and i mean i i always hear
that guys show like nudes to their
friends and stuff girls do the same
thing
too okay okay but i'm not i'm not
talking about like i i'm sorry i'm not
into like that stuff so right um but i
just wouldn't want something like that
of me out there so if i
if i was like dating someone and i found
out he like took that without me knowing
i would have oh my god i'd be pissed no
i know i hate i understand i understand
why it's not like i don't understand why
i'm just saying
we are living it's like
my whole thing is like there's an adapt
or die culture going on right now and a
lot of the people that don't adapt get
either eaten up or left behind in the
culture in which we live in an ideal
world no no one should record in anyone
we don't live in that world we live in a
world where people are going to go into
the trash and try and put a condom in
their vagina and get hot sauce instead
do you know what i mean so it's like if
we're living in that we're living in a
time a woman can write a book saying how
do you destroy a man by leveraging alec
this is the times we're living in so
it's like people are going to have to
adapt can i ask a question an important
question about that book who published
it
it's on amazon um is it self-published
or i i don't know who published it but
it's on amazon yeah i also was going to
add is that because it's quite
interesting about the whole recording
element as well because again in my
situation and it's what i mean about
protection and if it was the other way
around it wouldn't have been the case
but even when i brought forward to the
judge
the recordings
they had no issue they didn't want to
see it
i would have to pay 5 000. so the court
was basically saying to me
to
to you know it's almost like strategize
let's go back to court in three months
if things change if things get better
then you know but that's why i was
interested in about this point about the
abuse because those scars that that
torment abuse violence and is it
coercive control
that just has to sit with me and i'm
good
but another man would not have might
have been even myself i do question like
how certain things why i'm not in
another place but you know i think it's
very important to have these discussions
um and that's why i said earlier
there
are cases and yours is a rare one when
you said that i was like whoa you had
evidence wow
where
mothers and women they can be
the worst of the worst but they'll still
have they'll still have their kids and
their father could be the right person
to take care of those kids and relieve
them of the situation that they're in
the mother literally has to be
the
bottom of the bottom of the bottom to
have her kids taken away she has to be
damned
like amusing her children for a man it's
quick you do something wrong boom your
kids are taken away from your visitation
you gotta go and see them in visitation
and all this stuff yeah and i think it
should automatically just be 50 50
custody like off the off the rep i don't
i don't think women automatically are
better parents just because they're
women
that's a misconception yeah and that's
good i think if men were given more
chances to be parents in the sense of
the baby's born
baby's breastfed
she's got to look after them she's got
to stay up at night or whatever it is
but i feel like because of the way
society is it doesn't encourage men to
be the night feeders it doesn't
encourage men to be the we don't have
breasts sorry um when i say night
feeders i mean in general like
my kid wasn't breastfed the whole time
he had bottles so really and truthfully
if he was encouraged to pick up that
bottle and say do you know what you
sleep i'm gonna feed and i'm gonna spend
who's working who's going to work
so if he does that
is he going to work in the morning to
bring home to bring home to provide for
the house
only to be breastfeeding when he's
supposed to be sleeping because he's got
work the next day saying about
yeah but that's what i'm saying balance
i'm not saying it has to be all the time
but if there was more if there was more
encouragement for men to be
more paternal
i wouldn't say maternal but let's just
say if they if they if it was more
encouraged and not looked down on
because when you see a man that's a stay
at home dad people are like men are men
are better single parents than mothers
on average
like that is
no i mean i would agree i know some
crazy moms like i know i know okay all
the parents like i don't know to be
honest most of my friends growing up
like
their parents stayed together but the
ones that i know that got divorced oh my
god i would i would 100 pick their dad
every single time because their mom was
freaking nuts
have you seen a mother always been have
you ever seen mother dairy said anyone
you've watched that it's a true film
she's still um i've heard it
so joanna crawford she's a hollywood
actress
what happened she well basically she
used to be she abused her children but
no one knew it's one of her children
came out later and said it but it's
called um
mother darius very very good very good
do you guys think um
do you guys think that
given the whole drake thing right do you
think that
there should be mandatory
um
dna tests when children are born yes yes
yes
yes hesitation
i mean now i would say that before you
say but absolutely yeah because i
actually i did that i feel like this is
oh hang on say that again i actually did
a dna test because of that yeah
definitely she let you do it she didn't
know this is a thing i didn't let her
know that i did it
and i didn't even tell her later that i
did it but later on
it had to come out that i did
you know because the dna test came out
mummy no i mean yeah
i mean
that's what i'm saying i'm not coming
here to be personal it's very difficult
but you've got to realize that a lot of
people having this experience so it's
more of a solution basis to what we
could do
you know one's been twice sure no i
agree i feel like if there were
mandatory dna tests
there's no argument there's no issue the
child is either your child is not yours
and i think it would expose those women
that love to do up here's your baby
yes but it's yeah
and the thing is this is the thing about
because
you know i'm going to say it because the
problem is right there is that men
always can be accused of going around
having children a woman could be
sleeping around with other men and
there you go so and you're not going to
bring on two children so women can do it
and hide it you know what when i was
younger i would watch the mori show and
women would bring on
5 10 11 12 men like oh this is my 20th
time this is the one and it's like how
how do you
going back to earlier how women know
when they are ovulating and when they
are having sex how do you not know who
you have sex with in that
five day span
to have you're doing that that much that
you don't know who your
baby father is understand women that how
can you share you and i'm sorry but how
can you share your body with so many
people like you're saying in such a
short space of time
it is disgusting
you don't need to stop okay just stop
do you know
this is one of the reasons yeah why this
is my personal rent now one of the
reasons why i think so many women are
upset at men speaking nowadays is
because men are realizing with the whole
mori show
with amber heard they're realizing just
how manipulative manipulative women can
be
and men generally didn't know that
before like i mean
we knew you know what i think it is it's
when it hits home
you know like we've we've all known
but when it actually happens to you yeah
you know and then you know what even
when it happens to you it's what levels
because again if it wasn't because of my
daughter's sake i might have just
because it's about it's like the whole
thing obsession men men can't be
obsessive but women can be a city and
that's accepted
that's very interesting
i am gonna flip it on these shows you do
see these men that come on it's not my
baby it's not mine it's not mine but you
can see the child looks like oh that's
the silly child looking like someone
this is subjective it turns out to
actually be their kids too yeah so it's
like
you really you sat you had a
relationship with the woman but because
you weren't truly truly in love with her
you didn't respect her you didn't care
for her so you didn't want the child to
be yours so you demonized the woman and
made it seem like oh she's sleeping
around she's doing she's doing that and
then it ended up to be yours no i
believe a lot of women fool themselves
into believing that they're actually in
relationships with men and they're just
having they're just getting yeah why are
they picking these men like like it's on
you you say don't convince yourself
the men do their best to basically get
the women to a stage where it's like she
really likes me men like to chase they
chase and then when they get they
discard oh no girls ignore red flags all
the goddamn time
we know first three dates that this
man's a player and we keep going after
him and then we and then we go to the
internet and we cry boohoo poor me i'm
just like i'm in this situation with the
man that i pick
if you're a halfway attractive woman you
can date a million different guys that's
very true i remember guys pick they pick
so when a woman likes a guy
women control access to sex men control
access to relationships so you are
picking the man
and he's only picking whether he wants
to be in a relationship once you've made
the decision that oh i'm going to allow
this man to have sexual access never
thought of it like that that's right
yeah and
and as my grandma would say moreover it
goes back to what everyone said earlier
man
you have that con you if you have all
them doubts i think paul's even saying
if you had that you don't have to have
that child
so even if he's doing these things
you're a minoring you don't have to have
that child
i know everyone's got different reasons
of getting real child but i'm trying to
say you still have that power i just
can't get with this like victim like the
victim mentality i feel like as a woman
who we pick is our own fault and the
situations we get into our own
it's not the same with a man because as
a woman if we get pregnant we have the
option to not be a mother that that is a
choice they don't get that choice
choosing where he ejaculates his sperm
into a condom that we can take
into account
but there is
there is always a fail-safe option for
women even if we get pregnant by the
wrong guy we can get half his income
but that men don't have that option and
if they do it it's an exception and it's
not the rule and don't you know it ties
into it but what i'm seeing is because
there's that thing
do you know what it is there's that
thing where
see you don't realize the fact some
women want women on their own selfish
gains yeah
that when that child in their own
selfish gains and i think what poe is
actually highlighting it you still have
the option so all those doubts you
haven't met you don't have to have that
child you can control if i have a condom
if it goes wrong what i can get the next
day to prevent iud
hang on like i said
being head of security for your own
vagina yeah means anything that goes
inside is on you what can i just add
before anyone says anything else women
women use it as power play so they don't
have any control over men other than
that they don't have men have financial
power
they have power over women in the sense
of if she's attracted to you speaking to
my sorry if she's attracted to you and
you're not attracted to her she might
still pursue but having the man's baby
is having control over his whole life
his whole life whatever
and that's something that a lot of women
like to do so regardless if she likes
you or not if she thinks you're a bum
she hates you now she has control of
your whole life because she has your
child she has control over your emotions
because she has your child she has
control over your finances because she
has your child do you see how it works i
hear what you see all of that control
control stuff here yeah when you really
take it into context
it becomes painful for the woman because
now you also have you have to look after
a child if you've chosen to be in a
situation because you should have
thought about that yeah it's the
consequences
the consequence of your own actions yeah
yeah that's why
you still on the chart but you can see
but women know you can still get out
like we don't live in a society that
it's a downer if you get a child because
the single people get that help no i'm
not saying you could listen
you live in a you you live in a society
where if you're a single mother they
will give you a house they will give you
money
they would literally clothe your
children like this is the society that
we live in if women women can have a
child
and benefit from having that child
financially no no a man having a child
does not benefit financially from having
that child that benefit that you're
talking about sorry pal but that benefit
that you're talking about right the
woman will get the house she'll get the
benefit she'll get whatever it is that's
given to her but is it enough to give
that child a decent quality of life what
does a man get
he gets to go on with his life he gets
to choose whether he stays or not
yeah
no
i'm saying no but he does though because
he he if he what he doesn't want he's
out there
no no you're right no
but you're looking for the exception
rather than the rule where are the men's
shelters there's a million women's
shelters where are the men's shelters
we don't have them no women
there's women's shelters yes
but the women's shelters are they really
helping the women as well they don't it
doesn't matter about that
the point is women the point is women
get bailed out for poor decisions they
either picked up they neither made a bad
decision in who they picked
or they made a bad like or they got
themselves into a situation that they
shouldn't have been in but whatever
hang on
do you know what happens to men that
make bad decisions they they they just
end up homeless
look they're on the streets i've just
told you sit there in a 2025k and see my
own daughter what i'm saying the mum
went to call and didn't have to pay now
because she went crying and went to
what's those women
women's shows the organization but
there's a particular one the giai or i
don't know well basically it's women
basically you can get legal aids so
women get legal aid even me men don't
get legal aid i don't get legal aid no
i'm not saying no no no i'm not saying
you may not got illegal aid but you you
know a lot of women that have got legal
aid right yeah okay so that's what i
mean do you know any men that got legal
aid
there are some men that can no do you
know any men ever got league wade um
no no
if a man does want to get legal aid it's
harder for them there's more stuff
there's more stuff for women you know
they say what they're saying is there's
more than why aren't you working my
friend yeah you need to go and get it
for yourself women get the man is not
hang on women get women get oh you know
what she's gonna need some help she's
gonna need some assistance let's give it
to her men don't get that generally in
society no
the thing is i'm not saying we should or
shouldn't i'm saying men have been able
to suck it up and generally get on with
it
they have but the thing is women women
can be expected
to get some some assistance expectation
is to do with you just said
so if a woman is on low income she will
get legal aid if a man is on low income
he will get leaked
but i know men who are entitled to legal
aid because they don't have jobs because
they're on benefits however the issue is
that men have the they have the option
to go and work because they don't have
the full responsibility of the child the
woman has no choice but to stay at home
and take the benefit which is why you
should stay with your man
who's my man no i'm just saying yeah
look at the face
no yours is a serious subject
again you got generally speaking you
just said that you get you just said it
yourself and we're saying you know lots
of women this is why it's about
generally speaking where everyone what
they're basically saying women are more
entitled there are women organizations
this thing of if you say misogyny you
want to talk about i only know some
people don't know even though what
sandri is yeah well and you even just
acknowledge that the woman gets the kids
the what yes yeah the woman yeah so
that's that's something i'm saying
that's not fair so it should be why
can't it be 50 50 and then go get like
the woman go get a job like you can work
just like he can
so so i don't like even in that
statement you're still showing that it's
the system is against men do you know
how many single mothers
they have the kids they have the job
their choice the extra job
no but you can't say it's their choice
because some of them didn't have the
choice but do you know how many single
fathers are doing the same thing
i do see that as well but there's more
like as a single father there's not an a
lot of things there to help them as
single mothers there are things that are
there to help them more so you know
where we say well we've been saying in
here today that men don't really speak
so much about their issues right
if men came out and were vulnerable and
did speak about what they needed
if they were single parents and they
needed x y and z and they voiced that
they would get that i liked it but i
liked it
whenever whenever we say this is wrong
this is a poor thing that happens to men
the language is always put it back on
the men it's your fault you don't no no
no no no no you don't say this
i know but you're implying it because
you said oh if they only did this then
they would get that instead of just
saying like that's messed up
it is messed up i'm not saying it's
their fault but if we're saying that men
don't speak about their issues
then we have to acknowledge that if they
don't speak about their issues they're
not gonna be comfortable to be
vulnerable to say hey i need to help
people but
men understand like like facing the
consequences of their own actions where
women are just used to being bailed out
because if we if women make a poor
choice society like like
society bails her out there's women's
shelters there's not men's shelters but
do you know what it is
sorry once again bro she's not with that
is that
men are okay
understanding that women are the
quote-unquote weaker sex than us that
they may need things that we don't
generally need
i think what the problem has become is
when women have had those things
the ego started to grow
and the arrogance started to grow and
they wanted to use that now against the
same people men who realized no you're
going to need that because you're more
vulnerable than we are do you get what
i'm saying and i think
that's the whole feminist movement for
you really might be the personal point
of view if the man
say for example they had the child but
they don't the second but if they if
she's she's creating a hypothetical
apology if the man
did so let's just say they had a child
and he said for example i'm going to
take sarah as an example you provide for
your child right you do everything
you're supposed to do right mm-hmm when
i'm allowed when you're allowed but when
you see that when i'm allowed
if you did it the way you wanted to
would the woman struggle
um
no okay
so if there were more in my opinion if
there were more men like you who did
what they were supposed to do
on a consistent basis we wouldn't have
this issue well but i'm not trying to
blame it on men i'm trying to blame i'm
not even trying to blame no one i'm
saying for the men that don't do what
they're supposed to do i'm just saying
it's a shame because you can't blame the
women if you help them how they were
supposed to be helped they wouldn't be
crying if we if we picked better men we
wouldn't be crying
if we if we picked better men did you
know that eighty percent eighty percent
eighty percent of women go after twenty
percent of men if you want a guy over
six foot that's 15 percent of men
they're they're um i don't
i don't i don't know the exact stat but
it's like 18 percent
of
they're just
i can't remember this one but
it's a small percentage of men that
father all the kids so we keep picking
men that already have kids and we'll see
oh he didn't take care of the last kid
but oh maybe he'll he'll kick his
character my baby mothers are always
fighting over one another and fighting
over the same do i do i feel bad if you
picked a guy that that didn't take care
of the last kid and now he's not taking
care of your kid no you picked him it's
your own damn fault
men because
because women are generally spoken about
because women are generally attracted to
the same type of man
and the type of man that displays that
kind of confidence that women like and
so that type of man is being um pursued
by a lot of women whereas there are what
60
60 of men that women don't even look at
and there's a lot more women
oh he doesn't have a job but let me
still pursue him like that that's a
choice and and we we keep putting it on
the men and saying oh but you're not
taking care of the kid but no you we
pick him he's got
something the other potential
about a guy who he had like a few really
good jobs and he was really um
i can't remember what it was he was
going to work somewhere anyway and he
was on like a
some kind of web chat and there was a
woman in the middle who was supposed to
be talking to him so he talked about the
nuclear physicist guy yes yes yes and
she hung up the phone on him oh yeah
yeah i mean that man any day yeah
because he was ah
this is the thing when wait how how old
are you and me yeah that's what i
already have to say
yeah go and say your choice what you're
20 i'm 27. so like before before like
you're very pretty right but i'm saying
i'm saying like before before you had
kids you could have picked that guy i'm
sure you had i'm sure you had men after
you left and right no
no no i did not um
because of the because of the age issues
you started yes one because of the age
one because i was a little bit of an
ugly duckling at a point um
and then when i did meet this man it was
like i was already stuck in this
situation so i didn't really date how i
should have but obviously since having
my children and being in this situation
i feel like i've learned so much
that i wouldn't discount the man that
was a nuclear physicist and i understand
why i wouldn't if that makes sense that
doesn't mean that like i'm saying yeah
obviously i'm joking i'm saying give me
that man any day yeah not necessarily
today right but
i feel why not today tomorrow because i
still feel like there's work that i need
to do on myself
um
and i need to be honest with myself
about that i still have children and i
don't want that to be an issue as well
because i don't want to bring a man into
my situation and make them responsible
for my children and it becomes an issue
later on
like i don't want to lay those
expectations on someone so i want to be
at a point where
i'm
i don't i don't even want to say
independent but like it would be nice to
have someone
but i need to be ready for that and i
need my children to be ready for that
too
i want to put forth the notion that
as a woman that shouldn't be like your
prime
thinking and the reason why i say that
is because
if a high value man like a nuclear
physicist comes along
that's a rare opportunity right you may
never get that again are you willing to
say oh because i'm not ready at this
moment in time i'm going to pass that up
because
you won't get this opportunity like it
doesn't come as often and our value goes
down the older we get true i mean for me
if if a high value man came
and he
really saw that potential in me ready or
not
he would show it just like we're saying
that sometimes men decide on
relationships if he was to really show
me look i really want you
because you possessed this quality and
this and this and this and
x y and z then it would probably make me
more open to but i wouldn't trust um i
don't trust men that come and be like oh
i want to do this for you and i want to
do that for you and i want to do that
for you because i don't know what your
real intentions are and i need to be
able to like we're saying look at those
red flags vet this person properly
especially because of the fact that i
have trouble i get that because you've
been through a certain situation so okay
i guess all the time as well it's that's
where you've
you that you you you're more patient
with those people 100 percent
you kind of rush into things but you you
take time definitely and within that
time you then get to work out if that
person is what they're saying say yeah
going back to the subject so would you
say that the recordings that you have
here
uh
and i'm talking to men in general like
would you advise
men to record
if they in a position where someone in
my circumstances
absolutely because as i said that was
warned countless times so it's not a
goal to straight away because beforehand
i tried cancelling i saw there were
certain angles i mean so areas that
may have been issues that i could have
dealt with and again that whole thing
about being a man
so trying to deal with it and that's in
the counseling and speaking to friends
family to try and sort the ish situation
out but when i could see
how it was getting our hands
and that that control was where that
control was going this is the coercive
control i then said you know what
this is necessary i need to record this
because already i remember i told you
about the saying about punching in the
face
and i'm you can't tell i don't i don't i
advocate don't hit no woman so don't
ever put me in that position don't never
make me that guy
like don't make me that guy in it so
yeah i have a question do you guys think
that if a girl hits a guy that he can
hit her back
hmm yeah you see i've had a whole
viral tick tock i know guys do it i me
personally
i don't feel that you need to you can
hold them we're physically strong
so you can hold you can you can hold a
woman in it yeah so i don't need to be
hitting back a woman if she's hitting me
because i think if she's hitting you an
object or using something to injure you
and you have to
then yeah but if it's physical
maybe not why not not if it's
fist and fist no
but if it's like she got a baseball back
bat and hit you over the head or
something then it might have to be done
why is it considered self-defense when
a man hits a woman and she retaliates
but it's not really considered that if a
woman hits a man he's physically
yeah but i said in my video we live in a
time where there are no men there are no
women men can be men and women men can
be women and women can be men so what
are you talking about
i think equal rights equal laughs baby
like i mean i'm sorry you hit a dude
expect to get hit like you should i
would never i wouldn't hit a guy i don't
think i think i don't think most men
want to hit women or choose to hit women
they hit women because they have no
choice yeah and now there are some men
there are some
i wouldn't go that far
you know i'm not saying every single guy
but in the situation i don't feel that
you know if there's a altercation men
the first thing they do is think oh i
want to hit a w i'm going to hit this
woman it's usually when no i i don't i
agree i don't know i'm sorry i keep
going
no i i agree with you i don't think
that's their initial like reaction
but i just i think as women we need to
be more accountable if you are if you
are hitting a man expect to get hit
there's a it's a difference if he hits
you first okay that's that's
self-defense but if you are decking a
man and like literally try and with the
intention to hurt him
and it doesn't even matter your intent
if you're hitting a guy like expect to
get hit you shouldn't be doing that
women they think is cute that's why
actually that was my man inmates
actually given challenge because i know
there are men that do that you know they
all got that behavior of control that
you know so i think that's why i had to
sort of say that but in terms of as
pearl's saying
the woman that wants to hit men those
women that want to put their hand on men
you know what i mean so
it doesn't have to be that kind of you
know we're not we're not in a boxing
ring i'd say this [ __ ] yeah
do you know generally that you're
physically stronger than a woman
yep yeah
it's how you know that ish do you
generally know that you're physically
stronger than a woman yes
women do you generally know that
someone's physically stronger than you
yes
right so if you know that
if you know that if you put your hands
on a man that's up to you
because i know that mike tyson's
physically stronger than me right right
and i'm not gonna go with mike tyson
that's so true like if you if you went
up to the rock and you hit him and you
got hit back no one would feel bad for
you
bro just like a girl that was weaker
than me came up to me like i'm pretty
tall i'm pretty strong if she came up to
me hit me and i hit her back no one
would feel bad for like forever can i
put something into perspective
do we all acknowledge that emotional
abuse exists
of course it does so you acknowledge
that a man can be emotionally abusive to
a woman right yes
of course this man
is continuously
emotionally abusing the woman and we've
established that women are more
emotional than men men are more physical
than women right
so if the woman is more emotional and he
is abusing her emotionally
but he is physical and she reacts in a
physical manner
why is it so confusing because we know
that now we get now but we get that boy
there's context
that's what i'm saying so the point is
what i'm trying to say is imagine like a
woman has been emotionally abused for
years and years and years and she's had
enough eventually she might decide to
pick up that baseball bat and deck him
alone i don't think does that mean
that's not an excuse
that's not an excuse
no but everyone does have a snap
everyone does have a snapping point i
get that everyone's got a breaking point
like pearl's just said that's still not
no that's not an excuse so i'm saying
then leave the situation like there's no
excuse for that if you if a girl does
that expect to get hit back yeah but you
guys feel like there's no excuse you
can't say that a man is physically
stronger than a woman okay let's flip it
let's flip it if a woman's emotionally
abusing a man and then he he freaks out
one day and decks her is that cool
because because you just excused it for
the woman is it cool
no you're right yeah okay
this is what i mean like we have this
society we always make excuses for women
but then that's the thing though this is
the thing the double standards exist
though but i think the double standard
is because
it's because obviously a man is seen as
more physical so if he does flip out
like when you actually put into context
it's the same thing so if we're looking
at equality then it should be looked at
exactly the same in the court isn't that
what you want it doesn't know what women
ask for equality
would it be i'm just saying in general
would it be the same if a
trans woman hit
a regular woman
would that be would you consider that
the same
um
i feel like
it's literally what happened
they in my opinion i didn't watch the
thing but from what i saw online i feel
like they were both abusive towards each
other they were both taking drugs
together they were both doing things to
each other and for whatever reason it's
come out yes she probably did she she
did she lied she said whatever they said
but then at the same time there was
videos of him acting wild and mad and
doing whatever but he would have never
gone to the police with it what the
difference is that she went to guys as
what pearl's been saying she knew that
she as a woman she could go and be
believed he's only done that in defense
other than that the yes they would have
people have toxic problems and as a
matter of fact that's one of the
recordings she said go you go tell them
johnny depp that you a man has been
abused they won't believe you um
so this is it so this is a and that is
one of the things that
let's flip it what if what if a man said
oh go to the police they won't believe
you would you would you believe it was
would you believe that it was mutual
like they were both hitting each other
if there's a man recording saying that
that's my experience
the
exactly what you just described it just
happened he literally he felt right
right so should because it's the same
thing should we just automatically
assume you guys were abusing each other
um
i don't want to assume i don't want to
say you should assume that we were
abusing each other but when you look at
the actual complexity of the situation
right abuse started from somewhere
so you have to kind of like understand
the root of it
and it's not to like excuse any type of
abuse towards each other
but
not to make it personal i'm not meaning
to make it personal guys but if a 16
year old girl
and a guy that is eight years older
and then he's continued doing whatever
he's doing for x amount of years
eventually she's going to defend herself
i understand that so it's like
it's difficult to say like i said i
admitted everything that i did
when i was even in the whole thing you
know the police told me
don't add that in there
don't say that
so when you're talking about the book of
how to destroy a man it's as if they
were trying to make me destroy him when
i was simply telling the truth and the
plain truth i missed that you said that
they said this is why we call it the
gray area because would you say they say
don't they told me
not and it was a female officer as well
because she knows how the system works
actually she understands that if you
allow them to have any leverage over you
in the court of law that the other
opposition will use that leverage
against you and manipulate in such a way
that it will kind of excuse the behavior
that he was doing towards you which
means the truth is not the truth but if
you want to really look at the situation
he was abusing me from the beginning as
a 16 year old girl
knowing that i was homeless
so at the end of the day it's like
you're using that my risk my reactions
and my responses to excuse his behavior
which makes me think that
it just feels like you can't get
anywhere in the world telling the truth
it's not that because obviously it's not
just
unfortunate situations it's like it's
the the problem is when they made the
justice system it's either guilty or
until proven innocent or innocent until
proven guilty
and even in amber heard johnny depp
she's not going to jail she got sued
yeah also i wanted to say did she not
also collect the bag from him that she
was supposed to give to charity and she
didn't yeah
yeah she could yeah
but it's it's just like that's the
system if you don't have enough evidence
like there's not much you can do
because even even amber heard she's
walking free she's just broke
do you guys actually think that the
reason why so many
women are doing this type of stuff to
men
um more so than
no sorry not me say that but what the
reason why it's risen
is because women are becoming more
masculine and men are becoming more
feminine i think it's because women
don't have consequences
like i just think there's less
consequences for women than there are
for men because if a man calls the
police
and says oh my there's my woman's
hitting me what happens
in germany rules differently i think
it's like that in germany actually right
i heard that the rules is equally like
that in germany it might be but there's
in the us at least there's a bunch of
cases where the man they still arrest
the dude even though he called the
police i'll get arrested i don't know
i got you knows i got ra yeah that's
what happened she called up got i got
arrested
and made up some stuff yeah if a girl is
found out to be lying about abuse or
anything like that i say send her to
jail what the hell that's that's insane
yeah there should be consequences and
then people will stop doing this what
happens when
there's proof
that or let me not even let's not even
just say proof but let's say like it's
evident that abuse started from
somewhere but it's ended up in them both
abusing each other what should be the
consequences of that what happens then
if they're both abusing each other in
the end well i think in the like it
should have been reported the first time
and if then you and then you retaliate
then it's kind of [ __ ] out a lot because
you're doing the same thing that is the
nature of abuse
with okay so so what'd you do because
you're asking the question but they
remember they real human beings
like you're
this is why we go to councillors they
can't help you you've got to help
yourselves so the other day they haven't
got
as close said if someone if it's a
person hit you when you're 16 and then
you've allowed them to you're 24. the
question is why have you allowed that to
happen why have you not seen the help
why is it only now you're getting angry
when you're 24 and going to police
that's what i'm just saying that's how
they look at it from the first time
someone got sick if it's someone out
there the first situation even with me
when i was going to the co when i went
to the so the the lawyers in that and i
was saying what's happened they said if
you're really that scared why don't you
press charges and that was it because i
was being emotional to it
but they don't deal with emotion they
deal with what you used to do at that
moment but then you've got you're okay
in my situation i was a child so when
you're a child
and you don't know certain things
because you're not talking but you're
not like the thing is you're not
bringing this evidence is not on paper
you remember you're saying it's not like
oh it's 16 and it's got a message and
you can see video of him eating you it's
true this is what i'm saying you're
talking about a collective thing that's
been happening for years they can't they
can't um
what's it called prosecute anyone just
on that do you know what it is
the evidence that went from when i was
16
was just really really [ __ ] up the
person that came to pick me up when the
incident happened
basically is saying
i'm not speaking up for you i do not
want to stand up for you i know what
happened i was there i came to help you
but i'm not going because people don't
want that the people don't want the
walhalla like it's just said this is
your i'm full just white people saying
we're as human this is i'm saying one
spit and hopefully
you know want to be in one shot this is
where the whole thing about men
recording now if men start recording now
i feel like it's just gonna be a battle
against each other if we actually like
we said before whose responsibility is
it to protect each other
each other now it depends what is the
recording you see this i'm saying about
context if you say that you i've been
punching you
then i'm and i haven't
it's not about all recording each other
there's context to you you don't record
always we're shouting each other so we
start recording yeah that's what that's
if people what i'm saying is if people
started recording in general right
a man records when the woman is acting
crazy a woman records when the man is
acting crazy
what's going to happen it's just going
to be maybe maybe people would stop
acting crazy yeah it's true
maybe i'd think twice about that yeah
maybe maybe people would pick better
partners and act less crazy um can i
just add something off topic kind of
i was gonna say
do you think that the legal system is
unfair to men because men are the
financial
the people that feed into the justice
system financially
yeah bread not bread winners but in the
sense of what we were talking about
earlier where women get legal aid yeah
so they're not paying for anything
whereas men they will be paying into the
justice system
as part of that funding their cases so
that you know
women are taken out of the system
through legal aid men are feeding into
the system with their own pocket so it
it's in the benefit of the justice
system to have men fighting the case do
you get what i mean you know what you
just put something like
the perspective really into perspective
and it sounds a little bit like a
conspiracy no no maybe but it's not a
conspiracy that think really think about
it if you're getting legal aid you are
taken out of the system because they're
paying for you
men are paid into the system and they're
the they're paying for the cogs to work
so the longer the man is paying in the
more money is generated do you get what
i'm saying so then they have to kind of
favor the man ever so slightly sometimes
what percent isn't there like the
majority of child support goes to the
state
yes yeah i can't remember the exact same
someone let me know in the chat
i don't think it's a majority but i
think they take a percentage they take a
massive percentage what's the percentage
it's
oh hold on i think someone in the chat
will let us know i feel like it's like
three point something no it's not no
it's bigger it's big we're talking
significant challenges
but well well ish google said i'm gonna
read some super chats because we just
got back
um sorry guys just so you guys know um
my priority is always the flow of the
conversation so if it takes me a second
to read the super chats i apologize i
really appreciate you all these super
chats go towards new equipment upgrades
like this week we're getting new lights
tomorrow
but the priority is always the flow of
the conversation over the super chats so
um if it takes me a second i apologize
okay so
let's see i'm gonna go back down to the
last one that i read
and actually read it from the top to the
bottom okay ten dollars from corey i'm
just going to say it the woman claiming
abuse
um is clearly lying i can't see why the
cops didn't believe her i i don't either
it seems like you're using abuse to
cover up your bad choice in men blacks
that panther it should be a crime to go
on social media before going to the
police the accused must either be proven
guilty by the law with evidence before
you publicly accuse them without any
evidence osmosis reacts she's got to go
to her therapist desmond
johnny was upset on video because he
lost 600 million and his mother just
passed a couple days before the video
shm excuses salone fedale never have i
ever struck a woman i walk or i walk or
run i'm wealthy with lots of quality
sexual options i have too much to lose
and i finish her immediately block her
and be done with her forever she wants
lawsuits in prison for me have
self-control black wolf inc the
sisterhood hood uber alleys is in full
effect pearl can you explain what the
sisterhood uber alleys tour is uber
alice alice is to our lovely guest 90
for topi pearl and panel when you ask a
girl a question have them repeat exactly
what you asked before they answer so you
can see if there's a disconnect
s-t-f-u-f-f-s girl in blue just proof
she didn't watch the trial osmosis
reacts
getting emotionally abused does not mean
that you can physically harm someone
strong enough to hit them strong enough
to leave kyle won women in blue has been
giving me bad vibes um lord commander
they won't pass up a few weeks with
future sushami
low haney if you look at animal world
almost all the offspring strays with
mother until they grow up it's natural
for the child to be with the mother not
the father
i'm just human the mra has been speaking
about men's issues since the 90s every
has been
malignated by feminists for years men
have been speaking up for the unfairness
we just aren't taken serious the forest
since you're in england there was a for
there was a channel called man woman
myth who showed injustices and social
services and unjust laws towards men who
was removed from youtube but this docker
documentary is still out there please
watch info vader 25 of men and
unknowingly parent children that's not
theirs that proves that
almost everything in red hill talks
about society would collapse in a day of
25 percent of men found out the child
wasn't theirs sentience um
a hundred dollar super chat thank you
sentience um men
men have all the power i thought women
were strong independent boss babes even
after acquiring power from men via an
offspring what does the women want with
the said power let take a look at the
stats of children from single mother
homes of absolute power corrupts
absolutely lucas another 100 super chat
thank you lucas um pearl's knowledge and
personality are hot
um james marks the um
the woman in blue has made poor life
decisions and needs to accept it and
move on she can be better shut the f up
to stfus jess you never said i didn't
know i was pregnant you never saw the
show i didn't know i was pregnant corty
jones bisexual woman 48.2 percent and
more than a quarter of heterosexual
women 28.3 percent um
oh do what okay um just human how to
destroy a man is a book published by eye
of universe they've been publishing
companies since 1999 and some poor
ambitious authors boy type hate towards
men is 100 acceptable and even
encouraged on social media any negative
comments about women are hate speech and
we'll get you banned stefan pierre
jerome men should practice lay them the
mike pence rule never be alone with a
woman always have a chaperone you know
that's actually people were making fun
of him back then but he is the last one
laughing now
britain kirkland could you answer my
earlier super chat it's on topic um i
thought i did um corty jones lesbian and
bisexual women experienced significantly
higher rates of sexual assault and and
grape compared to heterosexual women
doug mp okay that was the last one i
read um let me see he said i didn't do
his super chat earlier he gave i'm sorry
he gave 50 um he and his super chat
i saw it earlier
so
it's okay if you want to find it we'll
do it the next break you see that
chaperone
thing that they just said
um
[Music]
what happened like there was a guy that
had a chaperone yeah mike pence was
trump's vp
and um it was kind of interesting
because trump was like you know how
trump is and mike pence was like the
most clean cut like like conservative
like like true when you think of like a
traditional
conservative man like with one woman has
the like picture perfect family
and he had he was very religious and he
had a rule that he would not be alone
with a woman like that wasn't his wife
so if if he was with another woman he
would always have a chaperone and back
then everyone made fun of him they were
like why would you do that like you
can't be alone with a woman like making
fun of him
and it's interesting because after this
like me too culture
he was smart he was smart he must have a
really bad exp sorry he must have had a
really bad experience to do that i don't
think he i don't think he did if you
like he he doesn't really
complain about it he probably just
understands his system yeah
i think it's just in politics like
i think when you're a man and you have
power and money
there's always crazy women that are
going to try to get it their numbers
true and yeah that's the thing like and
the thing is
there's no handbook for men
to
to show them how to handle that type of
power
because you know power generally
corrupts people you know ultimate power
corrupts but
um
imagine that i don't know like you could
be a married man like i said tiger woods
and 18 women have said yeah i had sex
with that guy
and it's like
there's nothing i said no in men's
nature and i think it's a a lot of the
thing is that men know their nature and
they know they're weakened by it and
women know men's nature and they know
they can make a man weak
and so a lot of the time
she's just her face
like they know they can make a man weak
and
whether you believe in the religious
scriptures or not you can go back as far
as them and say samson and delilah adam
and eve like a man is always is downfall
a lot of men's downfall have always been
like women do you know what i mean
again
yeah it's always been like starting a
war
and so i think
i think we're living in a different time
now where that type of manipulation has
been like enhanced for women and they
know how to use it it's been encouraged
and it's been
it's been pedestals
it's been encouraged to manipulate men
in that way
so that we can exploit what they give to
us so financially
we want to be independent but we
acknowledge that men
give us financial
um give us more equity do you get what i
mean so we're independent but we want
your money too but even in there
and then just to add to that we don't
want marriage
which gives us the bond
and the entitled not entitlement
entities women to what men have but we
want what they have you don't have to
say that we have power but we
but then at the same time
what is our power we don't acknowledge
that part
you don't think women want marriage
i mean i feel like women want it they
just can't get it from the guys they
want no no that's true yeah
they want they want marriage on their
terms and that's not how marriage works
oh yeah yeah i want to marry you yeah
you know like wait so do you know the
type of men that women want to marry
they want to marry those top 20 percent
of men no no but like now you go to
socials you see you see women proposing
to men that is just i find that so oh
cringe
wait but
i'm confused first of all can i just say
something to some of the chats because i
feel like i've been attacked a little
bit which i did expect go ahead i didn't
expect
and i am getting my help that i need so
it's not it's not like i'm coming here
to just try and make it seem like i'm a
victim and whatever it is speaking on
what you're saying about um women
wanting to be independent but wanting
men's money i can tell you for a fact i
call myself the independent parent
because i am and i don't want them to
say anything about me nobody hang on
when i say being a woman no listen
listen quickly being a woman and being
independent you are saying oh sorry my
sorry this mic is a bit a bit true yeah
but
so being a woman and being independent
being a woman and being independent you
are saying you do not you're independent
yeah but really your independence
because you need a man to support what
you're doing for you to feel empowered
no inaudib
women are claiming independence but they
want all the thrills that come with
relationships and marriage so which one
do you want because there's a level of
sacrifice and partnership that comes
with
not even compromise just partnership
partnership is being able to communicate
being able to listen being able to
commit to conflict resolution
take accountability for your part to
play in the problem
take accountability for
your position in your partnership but
wait when a woman accepts that
accountability for their part to play
they're looked at oh so you did do this
yeah you did do that and so
then what happened no no but so what
because i feel like it makes it easier
for a woman to be blamed no no so what
you're taking accountability for your
part to play right and somebody else's
opinion on your part to play is
irrelevant your relationship is what
you're accountable for right so if you
and your partner have a discussion and
you both acknowledge your accountability
in the in the problem it can be resolved
but the problem is the problem is
everybody
is you it's me yeah excuse me
that's but that's the issue i feel like
is we're in a situation this is what i
was saying about the recording each
other it becomes a war on well look you
did this but look you did that so what
is the benefit of
both women and men recording i told you
earlier women don't go to jail i have
i've never mendy
had a reason for a guy to record me like
i don't wait what is that women don't go
to women don't get arrested men that's
what i'm just trying to say this
remember
originally men all the time every day
get arrested for this okay including
myself you don't know how many men i've
been only women being arrested for a man
recording and showing to the police
do you know how many men are probably
sitting down in prison right now wishing
that they recorded something that had
actually happened to them
um it made me wonder
specifically with a johnny heard thing
johnny heard johnny depp thing um
that
had he not how many men did not have
what he had
how many men
are sitting down in prison now thinking
[ __ ] if i just recorded that [ __ ]
but i don't think because then just not
believed yeah but rape cases and all
that but him being johnny depp gave him
leverage in that situation
and it still happened to him that's the
crazy part
in that situation let's be real if
johnny depp was some
black guy from newham
and he was in that situation would he
get the same reception if johnny depp
was the average guy from down edmonton
some guy
would anybody care would they have
so much spotlight on it well it kind of
says that no
right but
that's my point it's like how many how
many average dudes
have been through the same situation
yeah how many averages have been for the
same situation and they're sitting down
in prison yeah i agree and i agree with
you on that but with the recordings or
not
you know
the recordings themselves they're not
they're not the ever evidence that
leverage the case in this situation
really it was the fact it was a high
profile case it generated money again
it's about generating money
for the average mad he
as he's at a disadvantage at every point
so financially he's getting rinsed
um
emotionally he's getting rinsed he can't
talk about it there's nowhere for him to
turn
um
mentally where can you turn
do you get what i mean where is johnny
depp openly we get you you know
i get you i'm a man i understand yeah
yeah it really is just because they're a
man because men
sorry something that i've learned which
is being on the podcast and watching the
videos i've watched with pearl
men's
men's brains are
just they just operate so different from
women so you're saying just because
you're a man it's like yeah just because
they're men they understand and that's
that's how simple it is when it comes to
men's brain it's
it's
mind-blowing men is simple
yeah it's mind-blowing that it's just
like that because i'm like wait how how
what do you mean just because you're a
man how do you understand that and like
women's brains they
think so much more about menses
it's kind of like how men they like
they'll never understand how crazy we
feel like a week before a period like
three days they will never understand
just how irrational and how not like
yourself like they will never have that
feeling this is this is where the
emotion comes into it when we're talking
about like obviously like we said it's
not acceptable when we talk about like
women's emotions and their responses
sometimes we are irrational as women
simply because we have certain hormones
and it doesn't make it acceptable
but it's like there have been cases
where
because of that alone or simply because
a woman has recently given birth or she
was on her period or whatever it was
unfortunately she has been excused from
certain things because she was not in
her right frame of mind when committed
are you saying that are you now saying
that being on your period is some kind
of mental schizophrenia or something
because being on your period the pain
that you get on your period
to be equivalent to having a heart
attack
[Music]
i don't believe you didn't hear that i
don't believe that
you're period you don't have a
discussion
guys guys
there might there might be a study that
says that but like some studies i just i
don't believe that's a big dangerous
thing
i wouldn't say that for all women there
are some women who go through severe
severe
period cramps for me i don't
i don't
deal with that mine aren't severe so for
me to
for as a woman be like oh so if this
woman
says that she can do this that in the
third on her period and her cramps are
astronomical no one knows what i'm going
through no one knows how i'm dealing
with it so i can use that as an excuse
i was just about to say you know it was
it's almost even though it's cool and
everything that's almost dangerous what
not to say you've done intentionally but
i was gonna say that when you get fit at
the press so when you go into those
meetings where women will talk about
problems and things happen they'll make
that their problem
so what you've just said they you've got
women in here that don't agree
and just like what was it just like when
me and stephen they said about us men we
understand we're not understanding
because we just understand we can give
you examples as to why we're saying in
terms of protecting ourselves and the
serious consequences has happened
as regards of not having that evidence
women we might have that evidence and as
pearl just said to you
you hear me she um um and what's her
name i forgot
she walked
she's walked so all of that situation if
it was the other way around
johnny jet would be in jail and that's
that's what we're trying to say period
wait but wait before you carry on before
you can can you put your phone away
please oh sorry thank you i appreciate
that i wanted to read the um the thing
about okay yeah and i go ahead okay so
i'm gonna read it and then i'm gonna put
my phone down so
menstrual cramps
or
dysmenorrhea
has been
sorry my
as it's technically called has finally
been ruled as painful as having a heart
attack professor of reproductive health
at university college of london i would
say some i was yeah but is that used
but so even though
you one at a time a lot of participation
even even let's say that's true
it's still not an excuse and and when we
when we when you say things like
oh like but when you add a butt when you
add a butt it just takes away all the
accountability so you say a woman might
do this because but it should just be
that's wrong period but wait no but wait
yeah
we're saying this about women yeah and
period cramps and heart attacks yeah but
we're not saying to men it's not okay
for you to say i want to have sex so i'm
gonna do this and i'm going to do that
and then when you don't want to protect
yourself and a woman gets pregnant you
want to be annoyed because she has your
baby
but hey
so you are going to play something no no
okay so i don't like that's that's very
often that's very often
so the reason that i say that women are
more accountable for pregnancy than men
it's because we can go on the pill we
can get an iud we can require that the
people we sleep with wear condoms we can
choose abstinence we can wait till we're
to have sex till we are married and even
if it goes wrong we can get an abortion
after pill yeah and the morning after
pill
all of that we can give up the kid for
adoption there are cases where the man
wants the kid and the mother still gave
it up for adoption where the men just
has a condom that she can steal
so
yeah i think it's our own damn fault
yes
however
what i'm saying about this period thing
is you're saying yeah but it doesn't
affect all women
it may affect different women at
different points of their lives so a
woman might have i might have a period
that's as painful as a heart attack this
week and next month it may be completely
light and painless but you don't know
what hormones are going through that
woman's body at that time i'm not saying
it's an excuse for women to do whatever
they want to do
but then why bring it up
by bringing it up at all because there's
complexities no there's no complexity
poor behavior is unacceptable i don't
care if she's on her period i don't care
what hormones she's on like poor
behavior is unacceptable from women make
it as unacceptable
for
men as it is for women it is to do well
it absolutely is we hear things like we
hear things like men are trash men are
the problem all the time what i don't
hear is men saying women are [ __ ]
that that i don't i don't not not at
this no no no in a public forum not yeah
that is not true it depends on the rap
song yeah
you see on social media oh she did this
and she where's men's empowerment
there's women's empowerment empowerment
no no there isn't
we need to support men more and we do
and i don't say that women see that as
soft women see that as yes they do
generally women women
one second women negate
men's feelings and i'm not saying
um that it's a good thing or a bad thing
i'm saying that when men become
quote-unquote emotional
they have to do it in a space
with maybe other men because a lot of
the time
if they if men come out in a public
forum
and do it where they're women watching
there are so many women ready to just
like oh look at this guy is soft and
blah blah blah
there are so many women willing to do
that and honestly it's the women asking
the men to be emotionally available like
even when we're advocating for men we
make it about us like we want them to be
emotionally available but not too
emotionally available i've heard so many
women they'll say oh i want a man that
cries in front of me i want a man that's
emotional like oh my god as soon as he
does it oh no not that much don't cry
that much don't be that emotional it's
like what what do women want do you want
them to be emotional or do you want him
to be just hung like strung up and just
hard and not expressing any emotion at
all it's like what you can't have you
can't have
that's why you want to stream but have
like stipulation you can cry but not on
these days these days and these days and
not like this this and this you're not
allowing but why am i struggling every
day no not i don't know
what i'm saying i'm not saying
everything you're like
i'm not saying every day but when a a
man when a man is with a woman he wants
to be able to be
free he wants to be able to be free and
have a peace and if a woman is saying
you can do this you can do that but like
this like that that's not being free
that that's not letting them be able to
be themselves so they're not going to
talk about they're just not going to
express it as a whole because you're
putting stipulations on how they can
express themselves so why why do it
anyways
and that's why i keep telling men and as
mr quote-unquote as misogynistic as it
may sound stop listening to women wait
questions just stop listening to women
they don't even know what they want on a
day-to-day week-to-week month tomorrow
question for the men in the room if you
were in a relationship all three of you
with your woman
and she was accepting of it all would
you accept enough of everything of your
emotions of your your strength of
everything would you feel comfortable
to cry in front of her of course
[Music]
no
if she's accepting of you because i
understand my understanding of it is
she's allowing me to do these things
however once it is done and i do it's
gonna switch this there will be a switch
right consequences for my actions the
moment i cry i'll show
that kind of level of vulnerability
you will see the difference so then like
i said stop stop listen to women because
the reason why i said yes is because i
thought okay cool if you're in a
quote-unquote safe space with someone
you're willing to kind of do anything
and everything
but when ish but when ish broke it down
like that it's like yeah well you're
still kind of talking to a woman
as women we want a guy that can hold it
together
yeah why am i crying yeah like yeah for
what it's true it doesn't matter what
i'm saying it this one's saying we
accept this something there's a bit
about accepted we expect women being
emotional more of the emotional species
but i understand why am i crying to you
what i'm trying to say is clearly some
men want to be more emotional but they
feel like they can't yeah but i'm saying
give me an example why am i crying why
would i come i don't know and one of
your family members died i was gonna say
that i was gonna say that because a
family member of mine
my
i'm just gonna say it my dad had an
issue when his mother died and his
partner wasn't there for him so his
response was i'm going to go and do x y
and z and that's what he did but it
didn't help the situation
so my point is like as much as women act
off emotions so do men
but you see that it's not seen as
emotion but you see that that's that
context is more understandable because
that's a death and someone loved ones
when women don't generally only cry on
the death it could just cry because i
didn't get a job i missed the train that
woman's thingy like
the emotion of what men attach them into
crime we can accept because we'll cry
and do anything and it's cool
but when you're saying when i was
actually about a man crying
a man that is stunned that that's that
you wouldn't expect anyone to i would
expect sleep
women women will cry because they went
to work and their boss said something to
them and come home right and be like
something to me today
like guys
you're watching this
movie
sorry sorry sorry no i have to say team
my life coach got onto me because she
was confused why don't you cry
why do you tell me what is going on
comes you don't so you don't cry i do
but i don't cry over like the serious
things i don't cry over like
i didn't cry over what he what all these
things that he did to me
i can tell the story like i'm sitting
here with but you know women generally
there's a lot of women that's why
they're probably asking why you're not
crying there's also there's many many
women that block their feelings and they
cannot cry about the situations that are
painful to them they're turning into men
yeah women but then
you're describing yourself though women
turn into the men they want to marry
they become strong and independent
they chase the bag
and they become less emotional
and so they become the men that they
want but do you not feel like sometimes
women are left with no choice
i i think women face the consequences of
their own actions a 20 a 22 year old a
22 year old
childless attractive in shape woman
has a pic has the option to pick a good
man
and if she chooses not to there are
consequences and a lot of the time like
we said earlier on a childless
young fit woman
when faced with a nuclear physicist
right
that is a good man with a good job will
say
he got no personality
and then probably go with
i don't know tyrone she didn't even say
that yeah until until she hits her and
then until
and that same girl will hit her 30s
right and after she let all the bad boys
run through her all through her 20s go
to her 30s and said oh i would pick that
guy that's the one i want
yeah like and
where is men
whereas men are different and men will
be like
okay
cool what does she offer okay she can be
attractive enough slim enough fit enough
or whatever
he'll take the woman on the as the
checkout no but you know what i always
used to say i remember i said i'm back i
said men go for what they want women go
for what they can get
that's true
no no i thought about it no no wait you
said men go for what they want women go
for what they want men go for what they
can get
that's correct that's correct
did i not say that first
because smirnoff you confused me there
for a second like i always just get my
hair right because men men will go for
what they can get women go for what they
want and because men can accept because
men know what they can get and also
they're exercising their options
men can only exercise the options they
have available to them women
can get it
that's not what we said though
what do you mean earlier on in this
conversation we said that men choose the
relationships no no yeah and men give
them access actually so they give them
access
and women give access to sex so that
basically means that the woman might
want the relationship with the man but
because she can't get it all she can do
is give the sex right hoping and have
his baby in the relationship thinking
that she's going to get the relationship
and then manipulate his baby yeah but
now you're saying that
you're missing
yeah i didn't yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you didn't say that okay
but now you're saying that
men only get what they can do
okay i'll explain men are realistic so
if a man is 5 10 average looking he goes
for an average or slightly below average
looking girl a girl that's a five right
average looking uh maybe even overweight
we'll sleep with a guy that's a nine and
think she's on his level and then cry
years later because she wasted her time
pining for this guy that doesn't want
her and was out of her league to begin
with and none of her friends were nice
enough and kind enough to be honest with
her and tell her girl you're batting out
of your league why don't you get a guy
on your level not true because i know
men who have gone for women
and they've fallen for them deeply the
woman said i don't care how much money
you have how much dish you have whatever
it is i just don't like you and the guy
is crying
oh that's a small
no
you got all the you got all the
minorities around you
real
most men if you say i'm not interest
like there are girls that flirt with men
and lead them on and i see guys
following them around but if a girl says
you know i'm not interested i don't
really want anything to do with you most
men go away
and if they don't you can always call
the police and say i'm being
arrested
may not call the police and say woman's
harassing me oh sorry
sorry i say that and this is the point
what we're trying to say so if a man's
being too much you can always call the
police saying this arrest me if a
woman's harassing a man ain't gonna call
the police and say i'm being harassed
i'm around clearly all the minorities
you're around all the minority people
i've been stalked i've dealt with people
that are crying over women i've dealt
with all these different things so how
comes how i just want an explanation why
so people think i'm making it personal
to me but maybe it's because i've just
seen so many abnormalities that maybe
you guys see the difference of so that's
why it's confusing generally tend to
talk in generalities i know but and
you're you're tending to talk in the
minority of things so generally there's
a consensus that we can all agree on
generally
but your whole thing is i'mma bring it
back to the people that i know no it's
not about the people that i know it's
about the experiences that i've seen and
it's not just some of them are not do
you think your experiences are of the of
the wider public
um
i don't know because i don't know the
world i mean we have three girls in here
that say that your experience isn't the
norm and two men so it seems like it's
it's just
there's three people in here that are
pretty random and two guys
and we're all saying your experiences
aren't oh yeah three including my
producer we're all saying your
experiences aren't the norm and you
can't come to the conclusion that maybe
your experiences aren't the norm
i don't know because really
you know because from the research that
i've seen in regards to
whatever i can do and the people that
are around me
i can't give it exactly no because it's
easy because when you do that it kind of
it's too general like that's what you
said about the heart attack i mean that
what did you connect it with and then
you read it veins like none of these
women agreed with it none of you have
had extreme negotiating period claims do
you think do you think you have a need
to be right
no i don't feel like i have a need to be
right no i don't because it kind of
seems like it a little bit
because you don't really admit when
you're wrong like even when we're all
saying oh that's because i i have
admitted when i'm wrong okay i just
haven't seen it i'm just telling you
what i've what i've taken from you and
yeah conversation and how i've
experienced you it's like you're always
like you guys are talking that but
listen i know this
and it's like because i'm trying to show
you that as much as you're generalizing
it there is another side of things that
other people do we keep telling you
there's there's exceptions and there's
the rule like i've said this so many
times in the same conversation so then
what happens to people that
are the exceptions
what do you mean what happens to them
like you mean
like if we we will be here all day if we
spend
if we talk about every single exception
to every single rule
that's why i said if you give her an
example it's easier that's why
i'm saying an example if you actually
look at this well see this is the thing
i feel like even if i say it you're
gonna say yeah but this yeah but that if
you actually because you read the
statistics on domestic abuse towards men
but did you read the statistics towards
domestic abuse against women and if you
did read it if you did read it you would
turn around and say yeah most of them
are probably lying anyway no no no no no
no
no you just say one time
one at a time guys i'm telling you i
told you that earlier when i with
one-sided domestic abuse 70 of the time
it is the woman thirty percent of the
time it's still the men the other the
other times it's they're both abusing
each other so i looked at the the
research on both
and i'm trying to tell you when it comes
to coercive control and behavior we've
we've established that women are more
emotional so they react to emotions more
than they react to physical and this is
actually a conversation i had with a
friend so but i'm saying what i'm saying
is that is not an excuse no like like
that that's not an excuse but that's
actually
unfortunately is the nature of women who
are abused if you look at women who are
abused they will tell the statistic
actually is a woman probably leaves an
abusive relationship probably after
she's in the she's been abused over 30
times well then we should
leave sooner and i'm saying every time
every time you should educate more sorry
to cut you i don't i don't think it's
about education i think it's about
choices
it's about it's about like every time i
i feel like you always put it on the men
and i'm saying why don't we take
accountability for our actions if we are
picking these people and we we choose
not to leave but the accountability is
of women to educate other women on the
abuse if i'm saying i've i only left
after the 30th time or the 27th time why
can't i tell the next woman which i have
done and don't get me wrong i look at
these women like why the hell are you
still in the situation when you know
what the [ __ ] is going on excuse my
language when you know what is going on
and
you're you're talking to me about you're
complaining to me about it you're crying
about it you're sending these mad
messages and paragraphs and all of these
things so then don't then you end up
going back to it but clearly it's some
of these women or most of these women is
is to do with emotions you fall for
someone so deeply that you find it so
hard to let go right
that's that's an excuse
no no that is because you said oh we
fall in love so deeply like we can't
like oh no you made a choice what people
see like you see what paul was saying
and she flipped around early and you
went that's true so which that's the way
you're saying something but she's
agreeing but she's saying if it was a
flip side because when she flips that it
felt like you agreed it was a flip side
and a man has invested as he said some
men have been homeless they've tried to
love this woman you know like marriage
breakdowns most women are the ones who
um have the divorce and the man has
tried try try try what did the what do
other men say to other men move on
so regardless i know it's sad and this
is a harsh reality there you go it's a
harsh reality but what's pearl's
basically saying once you see those
flags there's only you can only walk
from it but that's what i'm trying to
say so clearly
obviously if we're saying that women are
more emotional and men are more physical
if women are more emotional wouldn't
they be the ones to
initiate coercive control more so than
men then
coercive control is an emotional thing
no because men know that women are more
emotional so they know that they will
react more to emotions than they would
to physical and that's what i'm trying
to say women react more to the emotional
than they do to the physical a woman can
be hit 50 to 100 times until he's
messing her up and telling her you can't
wear this you can't do this you can't go
here you can't see that person and then
eventually she's like hold on wait
you're controlling me but she accepted
the hitting she accepted the break yeah
wait that's coercive controlling
behavior is a guy telling you you can't
wear something or go somewhere
yeah if the person is isolating you from
your family
and your friends and telling you i don't
want you hanging around this friend
he's giving you a reason telling you
because it's this that that and the
third but then you end up you're stuck
in the house you can't go nowhere you
can't speak out i just i saw narcissism
look i i i witnessed somebody today a
woman right sending a voice note to her
ex-partner she is no longer in a
relationship with this man he is so
controlling that because she has
children with him he's annoyed because
she met a friend
outside of her why is she dealing with
him like equals because he's he's right
i'm starting to question the kind of
people you know
he's setting a boundary okay he's
setting a boundary he's saying i don't
want you to do this do that do that do
that do that and she has the choice i
can either keep dealing with him or not
deal with him so i don't think that's
coercive control like i've i've been
with a guy that was that was pretty
controlling but i'm never going to say
oh this is kind of coercive controlling
behavior no no let me finish
i'm never going to say oh this is
coercive controlling behavior boohoo
poor me i'm going to say okay i picked
that guy that was my bed i laid in it
and i left when i was too bad like i
just i can't stand excuses it's just
like we pick who we date but then pearl
isn't that isn't that a confidence thing
it's not no i'm pretty unconfident to be
honest i'm pretty insecure and it's just
it's just that i had a father that
didn't let me
make excuses for god damn everything
maybe that's what it is then maybe
because i'm saying it's an excuse can i
just connect but you are because you
keep you keep offering now but the the
reason why this you're saying that the
partner is sitting boundaries right yeah
if he she has the children 24 7 right
she has well not 24 7 but she has most
of the care of the children so he will
pick and choose when he has the child or
the children let's just say right and
then she for whatever reason is with
this one child out of let's just say the
five just to be anonymous but let's just
say they have five children okay and um
she's got one of the children and she
wants to go and meet her friend there is
nothing more nothing less there is no
issue with it it's not somebody that
she's sleeping with right she's gone to
meet the person she's been respectful
enough not to take the child into the
house she stood outside of the house and
had a conversation with the friend who
is a male and now the guy is saying hold
on wait but you took my child to this
person
is she not allowed to do that simply
because she is he is he threatening her
he's too personal
he's been threatening her but you're
saying this keeps perfecting your
personality nuances like this
exactly do we know this happens like
there are so many women that deal with
this and this is what i'm saying but it
makes it difficult when i said there's
so many women that choose that you're
saying they choose it and that choose
that yes but those are the same women
that have died because unfortunately
they chose that so does it make it
acceptable well it doesn't make it no it
doesn't make it acceptable but we should
take accountability for the men so what
the women that are dead should take
accountability they shouldn't have
stayed you go to them
far too extreme like like that's that's
sad
so when i said to you sorry to cut you
so when i saw the situation that
happened and i said oh i could have been
killed i could have added that bit to
make it more like i could have run into
debt dramatic and being more dramatic no
one is saying it's right what you're
trying to say is that it oh i just want
to say you're not hearing what i'm
saying you're listening and hearing it
all falls down to us
she's not saying that it's right but
only you can get yourself out okay what
the thing is how are you going to deal
with that see the thing is how are you
going to deal with that situation that
this person keeps doing it because the
police ain't going to do nothing
the pool ain't going to do nothing
so what are you going to do about it you
can only
mentally strengthen yourself right so
what she's basically saying is that the
ex
they're all excuses it doesn't mean
it's um which is using the word excuse
is that this is being that we justify
for this thing to keep continuing so you
and yourself
have to do things and get seek the help
or we need to seek the help to eradicate
that saving continuously spiraling out
of control hundreds understand what i'm
saying no one's saying
that oh it is right because this is
wrong this is controversial
hang on hang on the difference hang on
one second
i think we misquoted coercion um
coercion isn't like you you can't say
that it's coercion if someone's telling
you what to do or where to go it's only
coercion if it's under the threat of
violence
right so like no no i just looked up the
definition so yeah but men
understand
no one's coming to save us
i'm saying like so when you're talking
like this it's like
you've always got
someone to save you
men don't have no one to save them again
they had to save themselves so when so
when so so when shay's saying
you got this you got the courts are
going to act like that you got the
police are going to act like that right
who you got to rely on but did he not
just say that there's no one come to
save you and you actually have to figure
it out for yourself so that's so that's
what you're saying men accept that
medicare
yeah but with women it's always an
excuse so was that oh but someone else
should have done something but i was so
in love like he he was nice at first so
then that kind of defeats the whole
objective when we ask when you asked a
question earlier of should men protect
women or should they not
no that's a different context like see
like i i feel like sometimes when we're
making a point you bring up something
completely like off topic
though
that was a different context of if a
woman is in need of trouble
should a man and then she went on to say
and she was an example of them talking
about equality but so there was a that
was a different context to what we were
actually talking about now if the woman
cannot get herself out of this situation
and she is continuously abused
does she not then need help to get out
yes and i'll tell you what okay i'll
tell you from because it seems like it's
getting there if they have brothers
uncles men in the family and i've said
this to women before they should go and
contact those guys because men won't
abuse when there's other men that are
going to stand and protect because you
use the word early about protecting
moth bullies and men that do that they
do it to women that are vulnerable and
some women don't go and tell those men
because they don't want that man to get
in trouble
if it's really affecting your psyche go
and contact the men around in the family
and what if they don't have those men or
what if those men that's why i said
for them when they're vulnerable what do
they do is my questions and then it's
easy
like they need to accept and they need
to all of that but then in reality
it's like obviously i i cannot save the
world but i have said to this specific
woman you need to get out of the scene
you're saying so you're saying that she
hasn't got no male figure whatsoever in
that whole family that she can speak
that feels the need to protect her
enough
clearly because if they were going to
protect her enough so many people around
her have seen it so many people around
her have commented on it but they
haven't done anything about it i know
and that's why
i just see it
but she doesn't she doesn't leave right
so again she chooses not to leave
correct no she's left
but he won't leave him okay yeah he
won't leave him like does he threaten
her drag her like how does she get back
it's constant like oh because you went
to see this friend of yours they are not
in a relationship you know what does
that mean
does he pull her scream does he get
violent with her no
okay so okay so
violent but it's mental no no but it's a
choice
someone is continuous
if someone is continuously telling you
you're not even in a relationship with
them but the person is continuously
saying she's choosing torture you're
doing that you're doing this and it's
mentally affecting them to the point
where they're constantly irritated
they're agitated they're angry they're
fed up mm-hmm it's it's mentally
associated
she's already how does he how does he
know that she's going to
hang out with a friend or whatnot if she
doesn't tell him i've never seen him
it's to do with the children he
questions the children
okay well the kids can say the kids can
after after it happens
the kids can say what they want to say
but i've never i've never been in this
situation but i've witnessed it from
someone that is very very close to me
and i've told them why don't you
just like stop talking to them you're
not in a relationship with them you
don't have to check in with them you
don't you literally if it does not
concern the child you do not have to say
anything to them and that's a choice and
that's what that's what everyone's
saying is a choice yes they may question
the child he may say well you went to
your friends blah blah she has a choice
to
either
feed into what he is saying
get the things from him that he's saying
take it in or just say yes i did the
child is safe we we hang out outside
boom bam boom
and she doesn't she
doesn't have to give her you don't have
to engage you don't have to engage in
the team
because it's emotional yeah yeah it
becomes difficult because it's emotional
the thing is i've been there right i've
been involved in emotional situations
where i've
looked at my behavior afterwards and be
like oh someone you shouldn't even have
got involved but you get drawn in or you
get drawn out right that's what we get
but
what you have to understand is that
if time after time after time you have
no self-reflection and you have no um
no introspection as to how you keep
getting into the same situation and the
same result keeps on happening
it comes there comes a time when you now
have to say what am i doing why i keep
getting myself into the situation and
the same result keeps on happening
because you
keep engaging in something that you
actually don't need to and maybe you
need tools to understand and to work
with as to how not to engage in that
situation anymore but it is still
your uh it's still your behaviors that
are getting yourself in situation
because how many times can someone
constantly slap you in your face
without you saying hang on a minute
do i like this no okay so what am i
gonna do to actually change this if you
continuously get slapped in your face
all the time then after a while
say the first three times that's on you
because you are now choosing to engage
in that behavior do restraining orders
or how are those easy to get in the uk
they're pretty easy to get in the us
sorry yeah yeah it's for women yeah so
they're they're so what is stopping her
from getting a restraining order i don't
think so restraining just is there
anything stopping can i just get yes or
no is there anything stopping her from
getting one no okay so it's again it's a
choice
you tell me maybe you need to just tell
her that because if you're saying you
feel passionate about it because what
she will come back and say is yeah but
what happens is that shut up
okay this is what you need to do you
just get restraining order and shut your
mouth and you're right and i think and
and i think sorry i think a lot of women
do not have the men around them to say
shut up and get on with it because the
bottom line is if you keep coming back
to me as a man and i keep hearing the
same thing repeated over and over and
over and over again men are people who
want to get things
done so when you come to even if you've
got a man and you can you come home and
you start saying this happened at work
that happened
the man's
because he's trying to find a solution
and now if you are not if you are not
trying to find a solution i'm i'm not
trying to hear you and i want to add to
this once you let
also people allow this a woman allow
this to come in this case and i've heard
from other women not just myself as a
man realized women some women actually
like that that's all that passionate
stuff
that's all of that whole kind of fiery
toxic and then you know he's crazy over
me somebody loves me at the same time
but they wouldn't tell you but they'd
like to come continue to complain about
it but they generally enjoy it as well
because it means that they still care so
like maybe as you said jessica said
earlier about how did she know that
she's meeting someone if you know the
type of guy maybe she i'm not saying
she's because i'm i'm just trying to say
some from experiences and hearing if she
keeps allowing this to happen also there
might be a possibility she enjoys it
happening but i'm not saying the mother
of your child don't know what you're
doing day to day the mother of my child
don't know what i'm doing day to day
right but she couldn't no but the thing
is we're still in but you're you're
you're your child's father's not
involved with the children you said
right because you've cut it off right
our our mothers of our children are
still involved we're still involved with
our children but they don't know they
don't need to know what we're doing day
to day because now we're getting you too
involved to get to and now you've got
too much control over certain things you
don't need to know what i'm doing day to
day again it's to do with the emotion i
feel like women actually want to know
what's going on they it's like
this is a flip side now this is your
friend now again
can i just say this like i said earlier
it's about control and accountability
that's all it is
if you let a man know what's going on in
your life yeah you want him to know you
want it you know women if we want to
hide stuff
i'm not saying if we want to hire stuff
we can hide it better than whatever we
want it's true if we want it at the
forefront we'll put it at the forefront
and with
i'm not going to say all women a lot of
women they know that they want a
reaction that reaction means we've got
that that man's attention regardless if
we like him or not we've got control of
him you know in a way
we would but i don't like to admit it
but it gives us a sense of power over
him and like i said earlier
accountability
and what did i say
accountability and control these are the
two main things that in all of those
situations what we've spoken about i've
sat silently and listened
these are the two things that come up
every single time
do you know what you just said there
though about women wanting a reaction
yeah i'm sure you can uh testify and i'm
sure as a man i can testify that when
somebody wants to control when somebody
is a control freak when you don't give
them the access to control you yeah a
lot of the time it builds up they're
building it up they're thinking oh my
god i don't know what's going on and
then they just they're waiting for that
one chance
to get a chance to control you right and
a lot of the time met
whether it be men or women a lot of the
time you have to understand
i purposely i'm sure you do i purposely
tell you
to contact me via email
you don't ring my phone don't text me
contact me via email because what i'm
doing is i'm keeping a boundary for a
certain reason because if i let you in
too much you now feel like oh
well
i can now control some things here no
you cut you set that boundary from day
one well okay sorry i just want to say
because
that you have a level of maturity about
you you will do that but other men they
don't clock onto that part so they'll be
texting on whatsapp voice note in social
media think about it women can write
paragraphs on social media stories
saying how this guy did this showing
pictures and all kind of
kind of stuff but then when it comes
down to the direct communication and
accountability part for themselves they
can't do it they will sit on social
media think about these stories on like
these funny you know blog sites or
whatever they will sit there and
formulate
images and paragraphs a whole storyline
but then they'll say it's the man's
fault
women women know how to tell stories
they will purposely put themselves in a
situation where they could take a
picture and say oh look at this like
look at this bad man outside my house
and write a whole storyline
to get people on side with them do you
get one of these because they are one so
can we establish like speaking to the
mic sorry can we establish that
basically when it comes to like abuse
and recording yeah
it's a situation where
if
men and women did record
it probably would eliminate all of this
stuff because we just wouldn't act
inappropriately that's what paul said
earlier that's what yeah that's what
people said because when you think about
it if she was recording everything that
he was doing and when you were saying
about coercive control and behavior and
this is the thing it's like because of
control and behavior doesn't mean that
they're threatening all the time you
could do something they'll let it go
don't leave it and act like oh they
might manipulate you and
emotionally mentally whatever it is and
then after like a certain block of stuff
like it might be like six or seven
things then they'll be turning up at
your door banging down your door and
doing this and doing that so it's like
when it comes to question control it's
confusing but again if she had recorded
that
and actually acted on it and did what
she needed to do it probably would have
stopped just the same way when i
recorded this person
and gave it to her i needed to give it
to it stopped and he started doing it in
covert ways the more i even reported
that the covert eventually he gave up
because you now cannot do it anymore
because i'm saying everything that
you're doing and that's what pearl was
actually saying yeah this is what i'm
saying so in a nutshell yeah you're
saying that excuse me i'm appreciative
yeah uh before we get down is there any
super chats to read yeah let me read the
gray area that's what i call the
narcissist if you narcissism they
actually think called the gray the gray
rock is it called the grey rock that's
why it's interesting let me just refresh
did you ever find that last super
chat-ish
the one where the guy
no yes i think
okay oh wait what was it what was it um
do you think that men don't record
consent uh because it might make them
seem scared or weak i'll be answered oh
probably i would say yeah yeah um okay
so let me read the super chat so this is
gibberish y'all are like facts facts
facts and blue is like but garvey and
popsicle and feelings and cats and
whiskers and me me me um james burnett
um rooting for your success and glad
that you are putting this content out
there i'm getting married later this
year um slg saucer shelters for women
none for men lincoln ward lady in blue
your monologues are derailing the
conversation losing the point that's in
discussion please answer directly so the
conversation can move forward scfu girl
in blue will never blame women for their
own bs uh manny fresh
blue blue blue shirt did get the context
out of question right should society or
men have an obligation to protect women
even from their bad choices real from
sapia hi ali um tonight's outfit is so
pretty good job pearl thanks ali ellie's
my friend um sibo nissi boo do
restraining orders not exist in the uk
osmosis reacts more trauma based and bad
faith arguments huh that's interesting
five dollar super chat um silently
reformed um she's been through a lot so
she associates her really reality
reality with a traumatized point of view
her views are related to her life
experiences and that's the type of
people she keeps around her cebu nicube
this is why men shouldn't date single
mothers the baby dad can always slide
back in um mercian bystanders excuses is
a tool for the weak and incompetent
eddie e god bless pearl speaking the
truth stfu ffs
in my opinion the girl in the blue loves
to argue just human coercion is
manipulation under the threat of
violence it's morning star
lesbian women have the highest dv
overall over heterocouples stfu as bill
burr said be a man deny your feelings
and act like you have answers jordan
peterson says men should be the
strongest at your father's funeral
osmosis reacts you attract what you are
makes sense makes sense trauma follows
sentience gents never show any woman
your vulnerabilities she can use it
against you and she will be upset be
stoic forthright and the rock with her
emotional storm will crash against and
come to realize and respect your
boundaries she relies upon it's mourn
star a woman's arousal is almost
compromised when a man cries there are
studies on this also what a woman says
she's attracted to and what she's
actually aroused by are two different
things there are studies on that
necessary um the problem is that men
don't process emotions the same way
women do at all it's dangerous to tell
men to behave like women especially with
emotions alberta retro men's problem is
we care too much about what women want
avoid the clubs on ladies nights for a
year watch it disappear osmosis reacts
everything she says in her life is based
on trauma mgtow by logics women control
themselves at jobs so they don't get
fired billions of times per day so
honestly this this period thing is
stupid um david h with the recordings
were deaf depths leverage without it he
would be
he would be guilty regardless of his
status wealth and skin color 90 for tope
pearl in the panel do you know how
privileged it is to be a woman there's a
war going on at the end of the dollar
but here we are talking about female
issues there goes the the men there
might be drafted but go off um
s-t-f-u-f-f-s i can't find a study
online that proves anything many-fresh
impossible for the average single mom to
be independent they are net extractors
from the system and primarily paid into
by men
sibo nicube um disingenuous
point dysmorphia is a condition where
with abnor abnormal menstrual pain so
it's out of the ordinary it is like
saying a cancer is as painful as heart
attacks may be true but it's irrelevant
it's morningstar i think men for tampons
because he created it because his wife
was in so much
pain he risked his career for her stfu
ffs race is irrelevant white johnny depp
spent seven years in hell um stf uffs my
ego was a culprit in my two failed
marriages dragon stallion one zero zero
one video is neutral it does not favor
one side or the other it only tells the
truth slg saucer 25 hairman versus sayer
court
case upheld 13 boys responsible for
child support after his statutory rapist
was prosecuted society has a double
standard um stf uffs pence might might
be devout and takes his vows seriously
marcus at pearl would you consider a
cosmetic surgery if your husband wanted
it nothing super excessive
why are you asking that marcus
what are you doing
he's like i'm going to pay for you if
you
i'm i'm good i'm
stephen pierre jerome women in the blue
you said that you were 16 um a child
when your abuse happened well what
happened from 18 to 24. corey i'm just
going to say it the woman claiming um oh
i think i read that one already um
black stir panther it should be a crime
to go on social media before that police
the accused must be proven guilty by law
with evidence before you publicly accuse
them without any substantial evidence um
okay i think that was all of them um
we've got two more super chats
refreshed
oh okay yeah i am mood we've got two
more super chats i think uh refresh the
page
okay two more
um
okay
the
um five dollar super chat um
lady in the blue you're not just driving
describing coercion that's a good that's
just gold good old-fashioned harassment
coercion is manipulation under the
threat to harm someone fifth fan 100
super chat thank you keep up the good
work pearl what do i get
[Laughter]
energy okay um i think that's all of
them thank you guys so much this was a
really um
a really productive stream i thought and
thank you for the super chats we're
getting new lights i'd really like to
get like two or three more cameras in
here so that's what all the super chats
are being used for right now so i really
appreciate you guys thank you
thank you all for coming um yeah and i
think it was a good
yeah so things were learned it was very
it was very real it was a very real
stream you wanted a blue one the one in
the blue whoever do whatever the one in
the blue
um like she has a name
yeah but guys please as we said before
like share subscribe
and um subscribe to my channel sarah
garvey and um thank you all for coming
and that's a wrap
so we call healthy baby damn i know it's
so hot in here